welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast in today's episode college
football finally makes its first-ever
appearance in the feats of strength
segment then Greg and I share some
practical tips for evaluating and
interpreting exercise and nutrition
research after that I present a read of
the week segment about the placebo
effect of believing that you're on a
diet and Greg discusses training lifts
variations that are different than your
competition lifts finally Greg shares
his onion jam recipe followed by an
interview with Alex Collier retourner
who tells us about his exciting new
research on muscle memory and the
effects of steroid use on muscle my own
nuclei remember if you're interested in
participating in Alex's current study
please feel free to email him using the
email address in the show description as
always thank you for listening and enjoy
the show welcome back to another episode
of be stronger by science podcast
I'm your host Eric Trexler and today is
a treat for the listeners I've got a
special temporary guest co-host and his
name is Greg knuckles Greg thanks for
coming by
yeah thanks for having me on absolutely
so we are gonna jump right into it today
and Greg has a couple excellent feats of
strength to share with us Greg what do
you got yeah so I I decided to keep it
brief this week I know that this segment
often tends to run fairly long last
episode where we did this it was after
boss of bosses 6 so there was a lot of
stuff to talk about there and USAPA
overall Nationals are coming up I'm sure
that there will be a lot to talk about
after raw Nats so I'm keeping a pretty
brief with just two feats of strength
this week so one of which and I
apologize in advance I know I'm gonna
butcher her name forgive me I'm American
we don't know how other languages work
but Ana Rosa I think that would be
pronounced cast a yawn it's CAS te ll AI
N and I think that ll would make a
wuyishan whatever anyway
so Argentine Argentinian female lifter
competed on back-to-back weekends and
set the IPF world records for the total
both raw and equipped which there have
been there have been in recent memory
several lifters who have had crossover
success competing both raw and equipped
I know
Blaine Sumner was the best or one of the
best raw and equipped super heavies in
the world for a while before ray
Williams came up and then he started
focusing only on single ply there have
been several others as well we had
Natalie Hansen on the podcast she had a
lot of success both for all and equipped
but again is now mostly doing equipped
Bret Gibbs has had success with both and
so I don't think this is totally
unprecedented I don't think it's
unprecedented for one person to hold
both the raw and equipped world records
in a single weight class at one time but
the fact that they were set on
back-to-back weekends is super super
impressive just because you know the
training required for both is a little
bit different you're you're not gonna be
working in gear if you're training for a
raw meat and you probably aren't going
to be doing a huge huge volume of 'roll
training if you're getting equip if
you're getting prepared for a single ply
meat because that equipped training is
gonna take a lot out of you so setting
both both of those world records on
back-to-back weekends any world records
impressive the circumstances under which
these are set make them even more
impressive it should be noted the way
the world records work for the IPF is
you have to basically be competing in a
meat that is big enough and prestigious
enough to set world records so there can
be situations where like a Federation's
national record may be higher than the
IPF world record and so it should be
noted that kelsey mccarthy who's a USA
PL lifter has hit a higher total in that
weight class she's totaled 680
and so the next time she can compete at
a world meet where or at a meet where
world records can be set it's likely
that this single ply records gonna be
taken but for the time being one lifter
taking down both the raw and equipped
records in her weight class on
back-to-back weekends absolutely insane
that is feat of strength number one
number two this is kind of a collective
feat of strength award but it's gonna go
to the Wisconsin Badgers offensive and
defensive lines not recent or not too
long ago they played against a
particular team up north
absolutely manhandled them on both sides
of the ball made them look like the kind
of second-tier program we've known they
are all along
so anyway looks like a good season for
Ohio State
due to that looking forward to the game
looking like a good season for Wisconsin
they're big boys upfront linemen don't
get the the credit they deserve
oftentimes but man Wisconsin's offensive
and defensive lines just just
embarrassed a particular team up north
and you really love to see it
it was wild I mean so obviously
Wisconsin has a tremendous running back
no question but there is this one run
that you know everyone's going on and on
about
oh god this running back is so good and
they replay the run and while he's like
a few yards away from the line of
scrimmage you cannot find a defender on
the television screen and it was like a
wide-angle shot like the blocking and
then obviously the defense just not be
being in the right place I mean all all
day Wisconsin's running backs even when
their star running back was out with a
brief injury no matter who was running
the ball was getting to the place they
wanted to be at with very minimal effort
the what their offensive line was doing
was really incredible to watch in
Michigan's quarterbacks we're just
getting pushed around all day yeah and
that's quarterbacks with an S which is
never a good sign
absolutely so yeah those those are the
feats of strength for the week and let's
let's move on to other stuff again
keeping in mind probably next episode
feats of strength will probably run a
little bit longer because I've seen how
some people's training for for all
Nationals has been going and I think
we're gonna have a lot to talk about
coming out of that meet yeah people are
looking very very strong it's gonna be
pretty wild so as you would imagine if
you're listening Greg and I spent a
decent amount of time talking to each
other
about recent research papers either
because we're reviewing them for the
podcast or for stronger by science or
for mass and say yeah we spend a lot of
time just kind of saying hey what do you
think of this one what do you think of
that one and so the other day we were
looking at a paper that caught our
attention and it kind of got us on a
discussion that we thought was well
suited for the podcast and the premise
of where the conversation started was
looking at a paper in the discussion
there's a lot of discussion about these
like pretty favorable results but then
when you look at the results section
you're like these ain't that favorable
and so there's kind of a mismatch
between what the results of the actual
study itself showed and then what the
authors wish to speak about in the
discussion and kind of the general
conclusions that were reached and it
kind of got us on this conversation of
you know if you're reading research or
if you're even reading a fitness
professionals interpretation of some
research you know how much stock really
should go into the text that's taken
from an introduction a discussion or
even even a conclusion section yeah so I
think I think most people know at this
point that it's probably not a great
idea to to just rely on the abstract to
you know draw inferences about what a
paper is saying
oftentimes I mean abstracts are 250
words paper might be 3000 words it's
it's hard to fully summarize a paper in
that few words you're probably going to
miss
key details and so you know I think most
people realize that if you really want
to get an idea of what the paper is
actually saying how the study was
actually conducted you should probably
pull up the full text but then in
actually talking to people about how
they read papers
I think academic folks and like lay
audiences who try to read science tend
to approach papers very very differently
so essentially like papers are going to
have four or five main sections it's
going to start with an introduction then
get on to the methods section then the
results section then the discussion
section and sometimes there's a
conclusion section or sometimes the
conclusion is just kind of the end of
the discussion and the way most papers
are written is the introduction is gonna
be written you know probably with some
level of jargon and an annoying amount
of passive voice but using words and
languages and like grammatical
structures that are going to be you know
pretty understandable to a lay audience
generally the same thing for the
discussion as well if it's you know like
really really nitty gritty like cellular
physiology or biochem stuff discussion
section may still be pretty Greek to you
but for the most part like exercise and
sports science papers the discussion
section is going to be pretty easy to
read as well but then if you look at the
methods sections like you know maybe
there's a phrase you say pretty Greek to
you yeah we get a lot of questions from
Greek people so what what he's saying
there out of great respect for your
culture I think that's a phrase that
it's unrecognizable yeah there's I feel
like we get about six questions a week
from people with Greek last names so I
want to get out ahead of this none of
which we pronounce correctly no we ruin
it every other there's a saying in
America it's all Greek to me meaning you
know you have no idea what it's saying
because basically no Americans speak the
speak Greek no but we do love your
culture yes so anyway yeah so then when
you get into the methods
action you know maybe there's particular
like measurements taken that you don't
really know what they mean the section
is certainly much more dry when you get
into the like stats part at the end of
the methods section if you don't have a
stats background
none of that may make any sense
whatsoever to you and sometimes if you
do know a little bit about stats it also
doesn't make sense to you but just
because the stats they used are dumb not
because you don't know what they're
literally saying that's a true story
so Greg you messaged me last night I
quote from a stats section I literally
looked at it three times I was like what
the hell are they saying yeah what
happened here yeah and then the results
section itself probably isn't going to
be as hard to get through as the method
section but it's still going to be
challenging because you know they're
they'll usually give like a plain text
summary of what they found but
oftentimes that's interspersed with you
know the the results of multiple
statistical tests in parentheses where
you may not know what those you know
figures and characters mean so you know
the the methods section is probably the
hardest section to read thoroughly and
understand results section a little bit
easier but still can be a slog to get
through but introduction and discussion
and a conclusion section if if the
journal allows for it those are those
are pretty easy reading and so a lot of
people when they first get into reading
research those are the sections they
focus on you know they'll read the
introduction maybe skim the methods but
probably just skip the methods maybe
read the results but probably just look
at tables and figures and then read the
discussion and you know like the authors
the people doing the research are
probably experts in the area where
they're doing the research so you're
thinking you know I'm a lay person I
don't have an academic background here's
how their return they're interpreting
their results their interpretations
probably better than mine because they
have more expertise here and so you just
kind of rely on the author's
interpretations of what they found in
the discussion section
instead of actually reading the methods
and results yourself and so I think that
that that is certainly understandable
but can get you into trouble sometimes
definitely I mean as you're going
through you know it's very appealing to
say I'll just kind of read through the
discussion and take it as it's given to
me just take it as as as factually
written and I think a lot of people tend
to underestimate the degree to which
there can be a little bit of
editorializing in the discussion and
there can often be we got a question in
the mass in the mass group the other day
that was saying like hey I found this
into this in a discussion I think it was
in like here's a statement with a
reference it seems as though they
totally misrepresented this reference
and and the answer was I didn't even
look into it but it looks like the
consensus was basically like yeah they
they kind of did I mean that happened in
one of my mass articles for this month
the the paper I was looking at there was
like the quasi meta-analysis looking at
the magnitude of the placebo effect the
reference they dropped in for the EPO
placebo didn't relate at all t-to EPO
like I searched it up I pulled up the
full text read the whole thing
thoroughly I'm like they don't mention
IPO at all in here
so yeah like I mean completely incorrect
references get dropped in all the time
yeah you'll find a couple instances
sometimes it'll be just like somebody
used like a referencing software that
just messed up and it's like that that
is not what you intended to cite and
sometimes it'll be someone who's taking
an extremely liberal approach to what
the paper really showed right you know
they'll take the one little grain of it
that kind of supports what they're
getting at and leave the rest that
happens to completely counter that and
so that you know that somebody was like
hey I this looks like a pretty pretty
critical oversight in this discussion
here and I think a lot of people
underestimate I'm not saying it's good
but I am saying it's common
I think it happens a lot more than a
person might expect and there's a
million reasons why that might be but I
would suspect that a lot of reviewers
who are generally doing it at 5:00 in
the morning or you know at midnight when
their family's like dude would you just
go to bed I don't think they're all
following up every single reference I
don't think that they are policing the
discussion and looking for any bit of
editorializing so I do think more often
than people would suspect some of that
slips through the cracks in the review
process so it's really important when
you're if you're looking at papers and
you just like find a quote from the
discussion even though that quote
occurred within the peer review
literature it doesn't hold as much
weight as the actual data yeah yeah
that's like you think like well peer
reviewed research is kind of at this
elevated level of factual nasur
truthiness if I could borrow a term from
like 2008 Stephen Colbert hell yeah but
there are layers within a paper of like
what is just straight-up data that's
like assuming it's collected well
essentially it is now fact like this is
what happened versus a slightly
editorialized spin on that data which
could be reflective of author bias and
that bias doesn't necessarily have to be
nefarious in nature mm-hmm so we bring
bias into any study we do because
presumably we began with hypothesis you
know what I mean like it's a little bit
difficult to separate yourself from what
you anticipated might happen within a
research study ideally you would be able
to but you know there are some inherent
biases that people bring into it and
then certainly there are in the various
cases in which people are doing it with
bad intentions you know they're trying
to further a point that you know in many
cases they're they're trying to monetize
that point correct I think is a safe way
to say that
yeah and so unfortunately I hate to say
it but sometimes when you read a paper
like you don't want to be like the
person who immediately jumps to
conspiracy theory but every now and then
I will see a paper where I'll go like
there seems to be a mismatch between the
results and the discussion or the
results in the conclusions and then you
check the conflict of interest
declarations and in many cases they'll
come out and say like hey I've got a
conflict of interest here just so you
know and you say okay well that that
certainly gives me some context through
which I can view these statements and I
can use some arbitrary form of how much
weight I want to put into them sometimes
conflicts aren't disclosed and so
sometimes I will actually I'll do some
digging if I see a discussion I'm like
what's happening here I'll look into the
background of like the lead author or
the senior author and see if I can
figure out like is there actually a
conflict here that maybe they don't feel
excited about cheering yeah and there's
not always a conflict like I think that
is the first place people's brains go a
lot of times but I mean most of the time
when when a discussion is spun in a
particular way it's either to make you
know maybe statistically significant
results with a small effect size seem
large and important or to make null
effects that are like maybe almost
statistically significant like basically
presented in the discussion as if it was
significant and meaningful and important
probably just do 2 to positive
publication bias like if you if you have
exciting positive findings that's going
to be more likely to get published
period and certainly more likely to get
published in a you know prestige
high-impact journal than the null
finding so you know the the spinning of
results there doesn't necessarily have
to be a conflict behind that beyond just
you know if the agenda of I want to get
this published and this may be the the
most favorable way to present these
findings in order to get them published
like that happens all the time even in
the absence of clear objective conflicts
absolutely yeah I mean you know
sometimes there are conflicts sometimes
there are just you know some of those
implicit pressures of how is this thing
going to get published but yeah it's
never a terrible idea if you if you see
statements that are strong enough that
cause you any any kind of concern of
like what's happening here this this is
almost reading like like advertising
copy more so than a discussion section
that that's when it's maybe not a
horrible idea to snoop around and see
what you can find you know I I got sent
a paper the other day where I was like
this this paper is kind of weird I
looked into it and like there's just
shady stuff all over it so another thing
to keep an eye out for again and this
may be due to a conflict of interest or
maybe just you know a little bit of
implicit bias of some ingrained bias of
what the researchers believe they know
about about the intervention they did
every now and then you'll see some very
selective interpretation of p-values
that are not statistically significant
but are close and what I mean by that is
every now and then you'll find a paper
where you know when the p-values are
like point o 8 and you know the
significance level that they selected is
0.05 if it's in the direction they
hypothesize they'll be like oh check the
salad close enough but when it's in the
other direction that's not what they
hypothesized they're like well it's not
significant what do you want me to do
like that's not useful information so if
you see that they are leaning very hard
one way when they get what what some
people might call a trend or a p-value
that's you know between 0.05 and 0.1 if
they're only leaning into that and
interpreting it when it supports what
they were looking for that's usually
indicative that you're maybe getting a
slightly a slightly biased
interpretation again not necessarily a
nefarious interpretation but it does
make you think ok so we're giving it a
little bit more
wiggle room in the interpretation here
yeah and and also if you see that
terminology in in a paper like if you
see point oh nine reported as a trend
that's a that in it in and of itself in
my opinion is evidence that people are
trying to spin it or or maybe just don't
know what they're talking about because
like if you you can simulate out data
and especially in small sample research
if you get a p-value less than point one
but above point oh five if you kept
collecting data with like
characteristics that would allow you to
get that you know low but not
significant p-value with a smaller
sample it's just as likely to trend back
towards a p-value of one as it is to
trend down to a p-value of below 0.05
it's not it's not a trend the way that
that's often interpreted is oh well we
had a small sample we had twelve people
per group but if we would have had
thirty this would have been significant
that's that's the implication a lot of
times but you can model that out it's
it's factually untrue it's it's not any
more likely that it that the p-value
would have gotten lower as that the
p-value would have gotten higher yes so
I actually just this morning was texting
one of our coaches Lauren Collins Oh
simple about this and I think we were
just both being smart asses I don't
think we actually disagreed about
anything but we were just arguing but
we're talking about the use of the word
trend and she was on your side I have a
slightly different view but I don't
think we disagree so with me I've
actually worked with statisticians who
are straight up bio stat you know like
their their dock their doctoral studies
were not in exercise they were in
statistics mm-hm and they they like to
use the word trend when the p-values
point oh seven point oh eight and so in
in what context so because the thing is
like it it depends
and and we're getting way off topic now
but it kind of so again you can model
this out and it's going to depend on
what size sample you're working with and
so like in our field it's almost always
small sample research and like 0.08 or
like 0.09 or whatever if you have a
sample of like ten people per group
again you can model this out and that's
not any more likely to go below 0.05 as
it is to go back towards one if it's
like point oh seven point oh six or
whatever and you're already dealing with
a sample of like sixty people per group
then yes it is been at that point more
likely to keep trending down yeah so all
I'm saying is that it's it's terminology
that has kind of entered the space now
and I actually it's not that I disagree
it's just that I'm more focused on how
it's presented so whether you say oh
here's a trend or here is a p-value that
is below point one oh that I wish to
further investigate or evaluate in an
exploratory manner to me it's more what
do you do with it not did you use the T
word or not yeah I mean I'm cuz I agree
the T word you I'm hung up on the
literal connotations of the word trend
Lauren is - yeah okay so good for her
yeah well not really we've been
discussing on Instagram possibly
starting our own podcast if you if you
if you don't promote me to permanent
guest host or co-host well so and so now
at this point we may have we may have
grounds to do that on we we agree about
the T word and you're a [ __ ] fraud
yeah well good first of all good luck
with your your new biostats podcast okay
I love that it's second of all check
your non-compete clause because that's
going to make your life very stressful
trust me but but in any case but I'm
more concerned about are you using that
to very forcefully say oh see yeah we
found what we wanted or are you using it
to say to like give an
actual thorough investigation like so
for instance you've got three different
measurements that are all like
hypertrophy measurements one of them is
a quote unquote trend the other two are
just clearly non significant are you
grasping at that to say like oh yeah
there was a hypertrophy benefit here or
are you saying oh okay well based on the
evidence available that's probably
nothing to get too excited about yeah
yeah or let's look at the actual
magnitude of that effect mm-hmm if it
was you know a quote-unquote trend and
the size of the effect was super small
anyway
then again who cares so I'm more
interested in how people use it after
they put whatever label they want on it
no yeah for sure I mean it's it's two
entirely different things if you know
let's say you have three measures you
have like lower body lean mass you have
vastus lateralis cross sectional area
and you have fiber cross sectional area
and let's say you know lower body lean
mass it kind of leans in one direction
p-value point oh seven or whatever and
the other two measures you know
equivalent high p-values like it doesn't
really seem like anything was going on
and then in the discussion section you
say oh but look at that lower body lean
mass this group clearly grew a lot more
than the other group versus you know if
like lower body lean mass was like 0.07
in one direction but then you look at
cross sectional area and fiber cross
sectional area and they're both
significant in the same direction then
you can probably look at the not quite
significant p-value of lower body lean
mass and you're like well okay this is a
slightly less precise measure we see
similar findings and quasi equivalent
measures in the same study so that
probably was trending to be significant
like those those are two different
situations yeah so without getting super
super far into the details on on stat
talk here
yeah just basically but try to look for
whether or not they're being an honest
broker of what when they're using that
that T word the the word trend is it
because they're trying to spend
something or is it because they're
saying oh here's a pattern in the data
that warrants some degree of examination
cautiously
and I think like
saying I think you me and Lauren all
agree on that it's just a matter of
terminology at that point fair enough
another thing you might find is people
making conclusions in a paper about
constructs that weren't actually
measured oh my god yes yes oh you know
you'll see a paper that's about EMG or
something and then the whole discussions
about hypertrophy and you're like ooh
okay you'll see something about short
term muscle protein synthesis rates and
again it's all you know very forceful
conclusions about hypertrophy which was
better or worse for it the same thing
with fat oxidation and like long-term
loss of fat mass and the same thing with
somebody doing like a sub max vo2 tests
and saying oh this is gonna help an
elite run or win a race now I will give
a little bit like the reason that all
these things happen is because there is
some small place for related things to
occur in research if in many cases not
all of these examples but like for this
if you're doing a study about muscle
protein synthesis rates theoretically
you might have an interest in either the
accretion or maintenance of muscle
tissue yeah like so it makes sense why
they would broach the topic but it's all
about being very cautious in their
language of what exactly did your study
show and what are you what are you
speculating could be potential avenues
for further investigation and I I think
it also depends so like varying acute
proxy measures to kind of extrapolate
that into what are likely to be
long-term differences there there's
varying degrees to which that may or may
not be justified so for example if you
look at acute muscle protein synthesis
and it's with an untrained population we
have we have pretty clear data showing
that if you if you look at acute muscle
protein synthesis data in an untrained
population and then have them trained
and then look to see how like that acute
session one muscle protein synthesis
correlates with long-term results not
that good like
not much of a relationship there but if
it's muscle protein synthesis data on
trained lifters who are probably going
to experience less less muscle damage
then you do see correlations between
acute muscle protein synthesis data and
long-term results so for example if it
was a study looking at acute MPs after
you know some some training intervention
or whatever like some new training idea
and one group did better than the other
you you still can't make a one-to-one
recommendation to say like we know that
these differences in muscle protein
synthesis are necessarily going to lead
to long-term differences in AI
hypertrophy but it's not completely
unjustified to suggest that there might
be a difference whereas if you did the
same study with untrained subjects and
then try to make the implication of oh
this is probably going to lead to long
term differences in hypertrophy that's
much much less justified because we know
that that proxy measure doesn't
correlate well with long term results
same stuff with or same thing with EMG
one of so for a long long time and and
this has changed a lot in the last three
or four years where you know the ideas
of the field are but for a long time you
would see it argued in the literature
that you needed high load training so
above 60% one rep max two calls robust
hypertrophy and there were several
reasons people argued that one of the
reasons they could argue it is there
wasn't much long-term data actually
comparing hypertrophy after high and low
load training but one of the like kind
of mechanistic I guess reasons that
people would argue that is they were
like look dude we take a set to failure
at 80% one rep max we take a set to
failure a 30% one rep max EMG all
throughout the set and certainly near
the point of failure just the whole
thing EMG is higher at 80% one rep max
its recruiting more motor units that's
going to lead to more growth and that
one reflects some level of ignorance
about what EMG is actually measuring and
then - that just hasn't panned out in
the
longitudinal evidence we still to this
day see higher EMG throughout an entire
set including at the point of failure
with higher load training yet when we
you know put people on high load versus
low load training programs you know over
1012 weeks we see similar muscle growth
so you see people you know trying to
draw a direct one-to-one line between
EMG hypertrophy you see that less now
than you used to but you still
occasionally see that and especially
when you're dealing with differences in
loading we know that's incredibly
unjustified but you'll you'll still see
people trying to you know extrapolate
that acute proxy measure to make
inferences about like the long-term
outcome people actually care about which
is hypertrophy yeah so it's it's tricky
because every time I find myself talking
about how people can kind of arm
themselves with a skillset to keep
themselves out of trouble with
misinterpreting research one of the
things that I struggle with is it often
does come down to certain aspects where
it's like you kind of just got a you
kind of have to have knowledge in the
area you know mm-hmm
so especially when it comes to
statistics or making the determination
of whether or not that acute proxy
measurement actually does give you
license to essentially extrapolate to
other outcomes there is some degree of
knowledge that's kind of required there
which is kind of an unfortunate reality
of like you you got to do a little bit
of digging sometimes and it really helps
we've mentioned several times on the on
the show like dig into a text book for
sure get a feeling for the for the basic
kind of theory underlying it and then
that'll equip you to kind of start
weeding through some research and
figuring things out but it is funny
because in the process of talking about
this stuff you and I kind of admitted to
our very radical ideas of what we
thought intro and discussion sections
should actually look like in papers
because I think we're just so annoyed of
just every now and then you do get that
paper that's so editorialized it's like
if you were just gonna share a bunch of
opinions why'd you bother collecting
data
you know like if the data wasn't gonna
inform your conclusion why bother
just just write a narrative review and
get it published in a journal where you
know the editor shares your biases
exactly which yeah that's a whole
different thing but yeah so like so like
I admitted like that for several years
my grad school colleagues can attest to
this I was probably just annoyed of how
much writing I was doing or something
but I was like an intro should be three
to five bullet points in a discussion
should be a paragraph like that if you
can't do it in that much then you know
think harder and your idea was that
discussion should basically be like a
miniaturized systematic review which is
interesting yeah I mean I think it
should go one of two different
directions so I think I think the value
of a good discussion section is it helps
contextualize the findings of a study
you know within the body of literature
that it will fall in and so like I I
agree that if you're if I think
something would probably it would be
good if something was done to minimize
spin and you can't really it's hard to
spin bullet points you can't really
develop you know train of argumentation
in the span of like five bullet points
to convince people of your particular
spin but but something else I think
could help as well as like especially if
if people are doing a study in an area
where maybe there's you know twenty or
thirty studies published already one of
the ways that you can kind of frame your
results is in in terms of the other
research you cite to say like oh here
are a few papers that found similar
results here a few papers that found
different results and you know it's hard
to accuse someone of selective reporting
and like cherry-picking references if
you know there's it's a journal with a
word count and you can't realistically
discuss the thirty different studies in
the area so you know you pick out four
or five that you've deemed to be
representative and you can selectively
choose those four or five that you talk
about to compare your results to and it
may be like you know
a few high quality studies that agree
with your paper and maybe like a few
low-quality studies that don't and you
can be like well when we look at these
handful of papers it seems like all the
good ones are leaning my direction and
like yeah some of the bad ones early are
leaning the other direction when that
may not at all be an accurate view of
that body of literature so I think that
like after going through the process of
writing a thesis I it was annoying as
hell but it it forced me to you know not
not read my biases into the literature
on the subject cuz it's like I got to do
a systematic search the to specific end
points in my research that I care about
I need to pull up read and summarize
every single paper in the area and so
like you know then if I did try to spend
the discussion people could just refer
back to the previous section of my
thesis and be like dude no like there's
eight papers here that are disagreeing
with you and you're not considering them
at all when you're discussing your
findings so I think I think if like a
discussion was kind of supposed to be a
quasi systematic overview of all of the
research and that was just the
expectation I think that that would
would help reduce spin-1 and then also I
think I think a fringe benefit would be
a lot of times like the same study will
get done like 45 different times because
for whatever reason journals publish it
every single time so we've mentioned on
the podcast before like the early
creatine research it was all like you
know we're gonna do three sets to
failure on bench press just creatine
help we're gonna do four sets to failure
on knee extensions as creatine helped
and it was like that for 50 [ __ ]
studies in 18 to 22 year old males right
and it was like did you really need to
do this study for the 20th time well
Gregg now we know well what I'm saying
is like you know four or five rep
replication attempts that's great I'm
all for that but if you were forced
like you know basically a systematic
review for your discussion by the time
you you have like 20 prior papers doing
the exact same study you're gonna be
like I don't want to do this [ __ ]
study again because I don't want to
write the discussion section
you know exactly as a person who did a
creatine study that featured repetitions
to fatigue as an outcome
I am personally hurt and offended and
shocked okay so I will add one thing
here if you're if you listen to that
discussion you said hey all of this
critically reading research stuff sounds
like a lot of work I wish I could pay
somebody to do it for me
you could always subscribe to mass
you're drunk
excellent excellent service so yeah just
to summarize this discussion we've been
having to bring us back to where we
started absolutely a million percent if
you want to know what a study saying
read beyond the abstract but also when
you pull up that paper start with the
methods and results section read those
sections see if do these methods make
sense
are there big holes here what are the
results
what are they literally saying and then
you know try to draw some of your own
conclusions and inferences and then go
back and read the introduction and
discussion see how you know the
inferences you draw maybe are the same
as the authors or maybe differ from the
authors and if they differ look to see
like you know are my interpretations a
better literal you know representation
of what this study found and are the
author spending this or you know maybe
it differs because you missed something
and the authors actually did the study
and their interpretation is better but
at minimum you can see if there's
possibly a conflict between what the
paper actually found and how those
results are represented in the
discussion section and I think that
that's going to help you get a better
understanding of the research itself and
to start being able to rely on your own
reading and not so much just
you know purely pulling up a paper and
relying on the authors to accurately
represent everything all the time
absolutely now I know the listeners have
gotten more than their fair share of
research and methods already we are
going to get into some very practical
lifting tips in a coach's corner segment
but before we do that I do want to share
one more interesting segment it was
going to be a research review but I
after reading the paper I called an
audible and it's been demoted to a read
of the week so the read of the week is
basically like a paper or really any
work of written text where you say
uh-huh look at that and so it's a paper
that basically what a lot of people were
kind of sharing about it or what seemed
to be the buzz in the public was this
idea that if you did a study and you put
two people on the same diet or two
groups you told one group hey this is
just a normal weight maintenance diet
but you told the other group this is a
weight loss diet basically you placebo
them on the same diet that there was way
more weight loss in the placebo group
and it turns out there's a little bit
more to that study than meets the eye
there are some very key details to keep
in mind which I wanted to bring people's
attention to so that they don't get too
excited about this concept of just
placebo in people into weight loss the
study is called studying a possible
placebo effect of an imaginary
low-calorie diet and I was like now this
is interesting
you know I you see that on the page you
look at the abstract you see the results
and you say I got to dive into this
thing to figure out what the heck just
happened and what you what you find is
that this is absolutely a psychology
study and absolutely not a nutrition
study and so that doesn't mean that that
it's not a valuable thing it doesn't
mean that there's not interesting
insight to be gleaned from it but if
you're anything like me and you're
thinking well
this work what are how do we kind of
follow this trail and figure out where
the calories went awry in terms of the
calories in calories out balanced
there's just not enough information in
the paper to actually comb through that
so very briefly the the the idea here
was to give two different groups to put
both of them at energy balance but to
tell one of the groups hey you're in a
big calorie deficit and to just see how
that would respond or how they would
respond in terms of body composition
outcomes and so what they did was they
told the group one group hey you're at a
energy balance you know you're you
should generally just be weight stable
throughout the intervention the other
group they said that every week you're
out of 5500 calorie deficit which in the
paper they said this should have
theoretically caused them to lose about
six kilograms in the eight-week study
they talked a little bit about the you
know eat the diets were supposed to be
55 60 percent carbohydrates blah blah
blah down the line
and they also had supervised training
Pro Train uh supervisor workouts and
that the workouts cumulative cumulative
we should have burned about 750 to 900
calories per week so that all sounds
like it's gonna go pretty well but you
start looking in the paper and there's
just not nearly enough actual data
provided now in terms of the results the
results are wild so the placebo group
went from 106 kilos to about 103 so they
lost like three kilos over this
eight-week period the experimental group
went from 113 kilos to 104 that's a
meaningful amount of weight loss like
that's a really big amount of weight
loss but so when I saw this I was
thinking like oh so you saw the title of
the of the paper and I figured the most
straightforward way to do that would be
to provide the meals for people mm-hmm
and so then they they really just don't
know exactly how many calories went into
the whole thing
but in reality they just kind of had
this weird kind of semi guided structure
where they just met with a dietician
every couple weeks talked about how
things went you know there's all sorts
of stuff in here that you just wish
there's more information they didn't
really talk about their pre study
training status as it pertains to
resistance training so it's hard to
factor in how changes and lean mass
might have been affecting things you
know that were some people new to
lifting and some people had been lifting
there just wasn't any information at all
about that they didn't ask them to
report food logs there's no quantifiable
measurement of how much food people
either eight or at least approximately
what they thought they ate there's
there's just no numbers in terms of how
many calories or what macros people
consumed there there was no quantifiable
measurement of adherence they just said
like yeah you know the dietician said a
few people slipped up but what are you
gonna do the stats were weird they
shouldn't have been weird it was a very
straightforward design there's no reason
the stat should have been weird but they
were so there are two groups and they
compared baseline values using a one by
two ANOVA why good question and then
they rather than just doing like a two
by two ANOVA you know two groups two
time points pre and post then they just
did within group t tests for the pre to
post changes within each group so the
stats should have been very
straightforward they were very much not
straightforward which whenever I see
that makes me really concerned about
proficiency yeah I mean best-case
scenario they're they don't know what
they're doing
worst case they're trying to get
something over on you right but the
thing is that difference was huge there
was no amount need any trickery yeah and
the difference between groups was
enormous there's there's no way that's
not a significant interaction right I
mean it's a small sample maybe they
wanted to hedge the bet but I just yeah
whenever I see really straightforward
protocols that result in really not
straightforward stats that to me is
always just
not great a couple a couple other things
so they measured body composition via
single frequency BIA
which those are numbers that like if a
client were to ask me hey I'm thinking
about using single frequency BIA I would
say please don't do that please just
don't bother because whatever number
you're getting from that I have no
confidence in whatsoever you know that a
couple quotes the study protocol lacked
any mechanisms for controlling the
adherence to the diet plan it was
possible that some over-enthusiastic
participants have been periodically
under eating and/or had increased their
routine daily physical activity another
thing was that they talked a little bit
about how the dietitian reported some
people deviated from the diet and they
said you know basically don't worry the
participants were experienced in dieting
and calculating energy values of
different foods and in most occasions
successfully maintained their calorie
intake Sall most unchanged so it's hard
to kind of indicate that these people
were placebo into thinking they were on
some really extreme caloric deficit if
they really were experienced and
educated enough to to do that in my
opinion yeah yeah I mean so it's kind of
like a catch-22 right because like
either they're not experienced with
tracking calories and macros they have
no idea what they're doing and they
probably [ __ ] it up because they
weren't given their meals or if there is
good at this stuff as you say they are
and they were already tracking their
nutrition and you can say in most cases
calorie intake swear unchanged that
means that they already knew their
baseline calories and you're right like
you couldn't placebo someone under that
circumstance right like there's there's
no way to spin that information in a way
that makes sense right so that was the
kind of the the main theme and I don't
want to be hypercritical this was more a
psychology paper than a nutrition paper
so if you read it as a nutrition paper
you end up at a lot of dead ends and
saying where's the information that I'm
looking
or so if you were looking at this as
like oh maybe I'm gonna maybe this is
gonna really influence the way I view
dieting or the way I view nutrition from
a physiology perspective it's not gonna
do that if you read it you're probably
gonna leave with more questions than you
came in with I'm not really super well
trained in the area of psychology and
when I say that what I really mean is I
have no training at all so you know I'm
not really in the business of carefully
critiquing psych studies but even I
think that you you don't you don't
psychology away 9 kilos right like
that's that's what it comes down to for
me yeah and and another thing is though
those carbon atoms left their body and
it wasn't through their brains another
thing that that trips me up with this is
like man if only it were that easy you
just tell somebody hey guess what you're
dieting now boom what was it 9 kilos
yeah ask anyone that's ever dyed it that
is not how it works
so I think what really happened if you
want to like dig behind the psychology
here I think what they told these people
was you're in the weight loss group and
you're gonna get measured in eight weeks
and I bet they they just were like oh
crap something's going wrong here I mean
the weight loss group I'm not losing any
weight they probably just deviated from
stuff yeah like it's it's gotta be as
simple as that right I mean you know we
know no one's ever lied to a dietitian
so I feel like that that possibility is
completely out the window and you're a
conspiracy theorist for even suggesting
it correct yeah but I will say this the
psychology of knowing you're going to be
measured later is powerful mm-hmm I
think that's the really interesting
thing here not the placebo effect I
think the really interesting psychology
again from a non psychologist with no
expertise is these people had skin in
the game and knew they were gonna be
accountable for it in eight weeks and
they're like I gotta make this happen
mm-hmm I think that's really what
happened but there is some kind of
fascination that we tend to have with
any any time we see a paper in the
nutrition and fitness world
where we believe that calories and
calories out broke down somehow whenever
we feel like there's some aberration and
it didn't work this time I feel like
people gravitate toward that which is
why I think people saw this and said
wait a minute they told them they're on
the diet but everything was constant and
they lost weight like and every time
it's just like this it's some sort of
like poorly controlled monstrosity right
so I anytime that calories and calories
out seems to be vulnerable people are
like oh wow what's happening here and it
makes sense mm-hmm and I think a lot of
times whenever you see any kind of like
sometimes people get really theoretical
about like if you do carnivore or keto
or fasting there's some magic happening
that completely defies calories and
calories out and I think that's why
people tend to really get super
enthusiastic about those topics but um
the thing about calories and calories
out is we view it as an equation with
two inputs
mm-hmm calories in and calories out
that's slightly over oversimplified
mathematically and whenever somebody
brings up a study like that like any any
kind of study that seems to indicate
that calories in calories out calories
out has been threatened in some way or
has failed us in some way I send them to
this paper by Kevin hall and I'll put
the link in the show notes but the paper
is called predicting metabolic
adaptation body weight change and energy
intake in humans was published in 2010
Kevin Hall's like the lead nutrition
researcher at the National Institutes of
Health and if you just go to the
appendix of that study don't even read
the study you can read this so when
you're reading this paper are you
accounting for the fact that it's
government propaganda
I'm just taking them at their word ooh I
know big mistake but if you just go to
the appendix so Kevin hall this is
basically Kevin hall trying to model
calories and calories out I think it's
like an oversimplified view of what
paper is the appendix contains 67
equations that collectively inform this
concept of calories and calories out and
how the body responds to various
exercise and nutrition inputs so there's
a lot going on there
I mean so one thing I'll say is I think
that so not with this particular paper
like not the Kevan Hall paper or the the
placebo diet paper you were just talking
about but I think that just in general
the the biggest place where people get
it twisted when they're thinking
calories and calories out and and we've
talked about this on the podcast before
with the concept of metabolic adaptation
but whether or not they realize it
they're operating with the assumption
that calories out is a constant term
yeah and so like if I or the only thing
that that's variable about it is
exercise so they think like you know if
I change my calorie intake and the
amount of cardio I do to these degrees
then I will get this level of
predictable weight loss like they I mean
the the thing that this whole paper does
really well is if you can actually make
it through all of the math it you can't
well you can't
I'm just messing with you but it it
shows you how variable all of that is so
like rather than thinking of non
exercise calories out is a constant term
that you know will always predictably be
exactly the same as it is today like
that is something that's highly variable
and I think in most instances where
people think calories and calories out
has broken down it's just like calories
out has changed and they think that
that's completely inconceivable yeah
people underestimate how much error is
associated with their estimation of the
calories in part so I think people read
a food label as if it is a perfect value
with a hundred percent reliability I
think people underestimate
how much error is in their intake
tracking even if they're pretty good at
doing it and yeah I think people don't
realize the very heavy math that goes
into the calories out part and so like
you see in this Kevin hall paper there
are terms to deal with de novo
lipogenesis gluconeogenesis all sorts
have met about the ketone formation all
sorts of metabolic fates of the various
things you're putting in your body that
in some way are being metabolized in a
way that affects essentially all aspects
of the calories in and calories out
equation so yeah that's just kind of
like a thing to get off my chest it's
like every time someone's like well how
do you explain this their calories were
the same but this group lost more and
it's like well I don't know let's look
at which of these 67 equations might
have been influenced yeah and it's not
like it's not hyperbole it's literally
just look in these and see if you find
any relevant terms and I promise you
will yeah I mean so one other thing that
this reminds me of and I won't
I won't tell the listeners that cut the
context in which we were initially
having this discussion but occasionally
you see some stuff in the research where
the really really well controlled
studies say one thing and the really
really poorly controlled or basically
uncontrolled studies say something else
I'm gonna give you a little hint here
you're generally better off going with
what the really well controlled studies
are saying and and so like in this case
people can make whatever arguments they
want against the calories in calories
out model but it it sure is incredibly
convenient that when you put folks in
metabolic wards and you know everything
they're eating you you know you're
tracking calories out very rigorously I
mean the thus far the calories in
calories out model is undefeated like it
but only in those scenarios yeah it
seems to work incredibly well when
you're actually controlling everything
and then as soon as the controls start
you know relaxing a little bit
you can find some papers where it looks
like ooh looks like looks like Kiko is
on the ropes but it's like wow I mean
what's the more likely thing like this
model that performs incredibly well
under circumstances where we can monitor
everything just suddenly stops working
as soon as we throw it out into the
world or maybe humans track something
wrong or didn't adhere perfectly to
their diet or whatever yeah so at that
point you just teach it as a controversy
right maybe says Express teach the
controversy baby hell yeah it's either
that physics broke or that maybe there
was some instance in which it wasn't
perfectly controlled outside of the lab
now I do want to I want to reiterate the
the paper I was talking about with the
placebo effect on dieting again I'm not
trying to disparage that author I'm sure
it was a you know an honest effort at
looking at an interesting psychological
premise but I think it was an instance
of someone who doesn't typically do diet
you know nutrition heavy research kind
of dipping their toes into that area
which is why a lot of the things that
you might be looking for in the paper
don't seem to be there and that's
totally okay and hopefully they'll
continue following up on how people
react to their diet and exercise
behaviors when they know they're on the
hook for weight loss because I again I
still think there's interesting stuff to
be gleaned from it I just hope that next
time they do a 2x2 anova it that that's
my honest thing that I can't get past
but I'm working on it
okay so I mentioned we had a coach's
corner segment coming up and this one
kind of started in the gym with us we
were we were doing some bench press and
I had mentioned to Greg that I I tend to
ban to bench with a super flat back and
I know I could get a few more pounds out
of it if I really tweaked my my form got
an arch kind of set up more like a power
lifter but I was like you know what this
just grows the hell out of my pecs it
feels good my shoulders like it so I
roll with it and it kind of got us on a
discussion about lifts that we use for
training
is lifts that we use for competing and
even with the same lift when when you
sometimes train with a slightly
different setup or technique than what
you compete with so so Greg do you mind
telling the listeners kind of your
experience with the concept yes so that
this isn't a new idea at all I'm sure it
predates even him but I know Fred
Hatfield dr. squat was a proponent of
this concept so he he did Hatfield
squats obviously which may have been him
trying to sell something you never know
but he other thing he advocated for was
doing like high bar deeper than
competition standard like Olympic style
squats in the offseason as a way to
build general Squatch strength and maybe
you know grow your quads a little bit
more and then you know he competed the
same way virtually all power lifters
compete like slightly below parallel low
bar but he did a lot of his offseason
training with you know high bar
squatting deeper than he would on the
platform that was something he advocated
for obviously worked really well for him
a lot of people tried his methods and
they worked well for those folks as well
and I've actually taken a really similar
approach to squatting myself partially
because I have garbage shoulder mobility
and so when I do a bunch of low bar
squats it it's not it doesn't feel great
for my elbows but yeah that's an old
injury right with the shoulder no that's
that's another thing I mean I I just
have garbage shoulder mobility and it
puts my left elbow and like bicep tendon
and I try to give you a pass you could
just blame it on the old wasn't it like
I I'd like to I mean that that affects
my bench press but it's just mobility
for squats but yeah so I've I've
historically always trained high bar
squat and front squat way more
frequently than I train low bar squat
and the thing is like I I think I think
people can get too carried away with
with variations of lifts such that they
may not have great crossover anymore so
for example something that was like a
hot topic in raw powerlifting five years
ago is box squats for raw lifters box
squats probably make a good training
lift for equipped lifters because like
you know you probably don't want to get
in full gear for every workout the squat
suit itself has stopping power somewhat
analogous to a box and so you know you
can you can squat to a box you know
throw some accommodating resistance on
so the strength curve may be a little
bit more similar to gear and like you
know get the job done without having to
spend three hours putting on a Leviathan
but you know maybe box squats aren't
such a great proxy proxy squat for raw
lifters but you know maybe Paul squats
are high bar squats if you're a low bar
squatter front squats just things that
in general allow for a longer range of
motion maybe are going to have a greater
hypertrophic effect for some of the
prime movers due to the longer ranges of
motion and then another key certainly
for myself and for some other people as
well as the consideration of like what
variation of this movement can I train
the hardest and for me personally if I
if I put as much volume into my low bar
squat as I put into my high bar squat my
hips would hate me my elbows would hate
me my back might hate me a little bit it
wouldn't be great however high bar squad
is is fantastic for me I can train it
with tremendously higher volume you know
push closer to failure without any ill
effects and so yeah there's there's the
idea of like you know are you going to
get a better training effect from always
training the variant of a lift that
you're going to put on the platform or
you know maybe are there context where a
close variation will give you a very
very similar training effect but you
know may allow you to train harder train
while getting less banged up in I
certainly don't think that's necessary
but I think it's beneficial
a lot of people so for example like in
the Shaco system I think everyone pretty
much always squats and benches the way
they would on the platform I think there
might be some like Close Grip and
incline worked in but it's basically
comp squats comp bench and some
variations on deadlift but basically
always with your primary stance so you
you certainly don't have to use
different variations to get the job done
but I think especially if the
competition version of one of your lifts
doesn't agree with you if you do it with
high volume it's worth considering can I
get the same training effect a similar
training effect or possibly even a
better training effect with something
that you know may allow me to put my
joints in a position that feels more
comfortable maybe will let me train
harder with higher volume possibly allow
me to get a good training effect while
limiting load on the bar a little bit I
think that those are all considerations
to keep in mind especially if the comp
version of one of your lifts allows you
to lift more but maybe doesn't really
agree with you yeah I mean I found
myself in this position with like I
mentioned with the bench press but also
with with the deadlift you know I'm one
of those people that if I train
conventional deadlift hard and heavy
consistently it's gonna give me issues
I've got a back issue that dates back to
my old wrestling days that really likes
to flare up so for me you know even
though I would never do a competition
with a sumo deadlift cuz it's just not
my strongest deadlift I still would you
know even back when I was when I was
getting ready for a powerlifting meet in
2012 and I fancied myself a power lifter
I would still mix in a generous amount
of sumo just because it was like if I do
another conventional workout here I'm
I'm not gonna be able to walk home it's
gonna be bad
so I think there's been some value for
me when it comes to mixing in my non
competition deadlift too so I can keep
training some kind of deadlift without
putting undue strain on those
pre-existing injuries now the only
remaining question I have about this is
if you are a competitor and you've been
spending some time training
either a lift or a setup for a lift
that's not what you're gonna compete
with when should you start switching
back to the way you're actually going to
compete so I have a pretty wishy-washy
answer for that
and it I think it's pretty hard it
depends but I'm not I'm not going to
give it a full cop-out answer I think
there are there are some pretty clear
things it depends on to allow us to make
this choice so one I think it depends on
how long you've been doing the
competition variant of a lift in the
first place so for example if you maybe
had a sports background and you always
trained the squat high bar for your
sport or you always train the benchpress
with like a shoulder width grip for your
sport and now you're getting into
powerlifting and you give low power
squats a try and you give a wider
benchpress grip a try and you've only
been messing around with those things
for like six months or so and you
already lift more than you did with your
old techniques but you know you're still
kind of getting acclimated to those
lifts I think that probably you're
you're gonna need to keep the exercises
you're still learning in your program as
you continue to to learn them so you
know maybe you'll still do some shoulder
with grip bench and some high bar squats
but every week or or at the very least
every two weeks you're gonna want to mix
in the competition variants of the lifts
that you're currently trying to learn
whereas you know if you've been
competing in powerlifting for ten years
and you've been you know squatting low
bar and benching with a wide grip and an
arch and you know pulling and with a
particular style doesn't really matter
if you've been doing all of those things
for years you've you know the lifts
you've basically mastered them your form
is locked in
you can probably deal with not having
them in your training year-round
constantly and then you know or you know
maybe doing them once a month or more
infrequently those motor patterns are
gonna stay fresh that you they have been
mastered to a degree that if they get a
little rusty they're gonna be perfectly
fine again within
two or three weeks of starting to train
them hard again so you know if you leave
them in your training you can probably
get away with doing that for like a
quarter of your squatting or benching or
dead lifting volume and really starting
to focus on them again you know six
weeks out eight weeks out from a meet
versus you know probably needing to keep
them in for a lot more of your training
if you're if you're newer to those lifts
and then I think another thing that
matters which is a little harder to
quantify I guess is just generally how
coordinated are you and how gifted are
you at like learning and maintaining new
motor skills so like I was someone
growing up who was pretty good at sports
and could pick up new skills pretty
quickly and for me like I can I cannot
do a competition variant of a squat for
six months the first time I try it again
it's gonna feel a little iffy like this
is weird my groups a little off second
time I do it it feels perfect I think
that if I was rolling up to a meet and I
had two sessions of low bar squats prior
to the meet I'd be fine
versus like you know other people who
maybe don't have the same athletic
background and who when you do learn
motor skills it takes you a little bit
longer to pick them up and to knock the
rust off you know you would probably
need to spend more time prior to a meet
specifically focusing on those skills
getting the motor patterns snappy again
greasing the groove you know before
trying to put that on the platform so I
think it depends just on the degree to
which you have mastered the movements at
some point in time and the degree to
which you can learn and maintain and
pick back up motor skills definitely
that makes sense I think that just about
does it for this episode but as always
we need something to play us out and you
know my my inbox is these days on social
media I basically only get two kinds of
messages
one message is saying please keep Greg
on as a permanent co-host and keep him
rolling in know as many you know
probably message Eric that and multiple
times per day I think I think that's
ideal those messages are not helpful at
all and in fact they actually make me
resent Greg more and more by the day the
other kind of message I get is hey can
you have Greg share more recipes so
today to play us out Greg is going to
share a recipe with us for his onion jam
and I got to be honest I was not aware
that onion jam is a thing I had never
heard of it until Greg made it because
my palate is remarkably unrefined but I
can say with great confidence this stuff
is really really good so Greg onion jam
how do you do it yeah man so onion jam I
think is possibly the most slept on
condiment out there you know people use
ketchup they use mustard they use
mayonnaise they use barbecue sauce they
use Vegemite I guess I've heard that
that's a thing but onion jam is
something that that a lot of people
don't know about and if you've heard of
it fewer people have tried it or
certainly attempted to make it
themselves but it's an incredibly
versatile condiment it has a really
complex flavor and it's also it's pretty
easy to to tweak the flavors and really
make it any sort of condiment you want
it to be just because if you if you look
at the great cuisines of the world a lot
of them start with a base including
onions so you know the the base of like
Creole cooking is onion and carrot and
pepper
I believe generally with some garlic
thrown in there as well a good fringe
mirepoix or an Italian sofrito that's
gonna be onions and carrots and celery
typically so I mean it's it's a base of
nonono Creole is the pepper instead of
the carrot but still with celery
please Creole people
don't hate me I did know that I said I
have no room in my inbox for messages
about Greg and his Creole knowledge so
yes so even those to him so all I'm
getting at is like for a lot of like you
know core cuisines of the world onions
are at the base of them because you can
get a lot of really good and interesting
flavors from onions and especially when
you cook them down you get the onion
enos and you also get a very interesting
type of sweetness like if you've ever
put caramelized onions on a hot dog or
on you know like a cheese steak or
something like they taste sweet but they
don't taste sweet the same way that like
barbecue sauce does or like certainly
honey or just something that's just
straight-up sweet like it's it's an
interesting complex sweetness so you can
do a lot of things with onion jams and
and add different flavors to make them
taste the way you want so the way that
you would start an onion jam is you get
a bunch of onions so I would probably
recommend starting with four-ish onions
chopping them up slicing them really
really fine so you don't want you know
big chunks of onions but but sliced and
not diced because you also don't want
tiny tiny little pieces either
so you thinly slice some onions you put
them in a pan and the traditional way to
make onion jam which i think is a little
bit more effort is you just put the
onions in the pan with some oil and just
cook them down the same way you would
make caramelized onions and then you add
other flavorings after that reason I
think that's a little more effort is you
don't want the onions to burn you want
them to caramelize but not burn and so
you you need to watch them closer and
keep stirring them and stay near them
with with that method so what I think
works better is you take the onions you
put them in a pot you cover them with
some sort of liquid and then as they
cook in the liquid they're gonna soften
they're gonna a lot of the starch is
gonna break down and then when the
liquid is gone they're gonna caramelize
really quickly and like the time you
have to act
we be watching it is much much shorter
than just starting it in a dry pan with
oil so you take the onions you slice
them fine cover them with some sort of
liquid I would recommend some sort of
stock either chicken stock or beef stock
and then the most most basic version is
you would add a little bit of oil or
butter to that pot you let the water
cook down the onions get soft once the
water is gone the onions are gonna start
caramelizing them it's going to start
caramelizing you turn down the heat
let them caramelize gradually and then
when they're about to get done you add a
little bit of sugar a lot of the recipes
I've seen online call for a huge amount
of sugar so I've seen the most recent
recipe I saw when I was looking for
other onion jam ideas was like like 3
onions and a cup of sugar that's [ __ ]
ridiculous you don't need that much
sugar for like 8 onions I go like 1/4
cup of sugar maybe 1/2 cup at most so a
little bit of sugar and then when all of
that's cooked down and like that sugar
has started to caramelize as well you
salt to taste you don't want to salt the
water initially because if that water
gets the level of salty you want it to
be by the time it cooks down and
concentrates it's going to be way too
salty
so you salt it near the end of the
process and then you basically just have
sweetened caramelized onions which is
the most basic form of onion jam however
like I said you can you can make it your
own so things that I would recommend is
throwing a few or throwing a little bit
of garlic into the mix once the liquid
has cooked down all the way just dice it
really really fine keep the heat low
enough that the garlic's not going to
burn
I mean onion an onion and garlic always
plays well together and I just love
garlic when you put the onions in the
pot with the stock you can throw some
fresh herbs in there so the onion jam I
have in the fridge right now I think I
went with bay leaves and thyme and they
play very very nicely together and go
well with the onions
to add a little bit more depth and
complexity you can add some wine into
the mix again throw that into the pot
when the onions are covered in stock all
of the alcohol will boil off and I think
white wine tends to work a little bit
better than red wine I think the red
wine flavor can start overpowering the
onions but throwing like a cup of white
wine into the mix is a good option
oftentimes you'll see onion jam recipes
with a tomato element to kick up the
umami so you can just use ketchup like
for four or five onions something like a
quarter cup of ketchup gets the job done
I have some homemade ketchup that's
amazing but store-bought works perfectly
fine would you be able to do perhaps
like a Shrek related ketchup that's
green in color would that be the same oh
yeah absolutely
perfect or what I see a lot of recipes
call for is tomato paste that's also
really good a lot a lot of free
glutamate gonna kick up the umami nough
Sal ittle bit another very common
addition you'll see the onion jam is
vinegar again that just adds another
element it's gonna add some sourness
into the mix you know you know sweet
salty sour like all of the interesting
flavors all in one thing so vinegar
strongly recommend playing around with
that to kick the umami up even more you
can add a little fish sauce I know that
that's something that a lot of Americans
probably don't have much experience
cooking with if you get some fish sauce
don't smell it before you cook it or
before you put it in a dish it smells
awful as long as you don't add way too
much
you're not gonna smell it by the time
it's cooked down it just adds like a ton
of free glutamate and again kicks up the
umami of the onion jam and then really
any powdered spices you're interested in
so something I like to throw in is a few
red pepper flakes so you got it all
going on you have the sweetness from the
onions and the sugar you have all of the
different herbs and spices you threw in
you have the savoriness kicked up from
the ketchup and the fish sauce you have
a little bit of sourness from the
vinegar and now you have a little heat
from
some pepper flakes it's it's an
incredibly complex flavor but anyway you
can mess around with any of those things
or none of those things and it's gonna
be good and you can customize it to the
taste you want on that backbone of
delicious caramelized onions and then in
terms of what you'd use it for
it's a condiment you can use it pretty
much wherever you would use a condiment
so when you hear onion jam probably
don't think oh I'm going to spread this
on toast in the morning it would be good
but it would certainly be a
non-traditional usage for it and it's
not going to replace like strawberry jam
but it's really good on sandwiches it's
really good on burgers
if you cook steak or pork chops like
throwing a little onion jam on top
delicious
works well on charcuterie boards if if
you're into that kind of thing and then
a kind of weird thing I do with it that
I personally love is I make scrambled
eggs every morning and I mix it in with
my eggs flavors play really nice
together so anyway a lot of great
condiments of the world
I think onion jam is is one that that's
fairly easy to make and it's very slept
on and it's very customizable so yeah if
you if you've just been wanting more
condiments in your life or another thing
that I'll note just in general is like
man if you have people coming over to
eat and you make the main course or like
you make some cookies for after the meal
or whatever people are gonna be like oh
that's nice they cooked for me and if
the food's good they're gonna be
impressed cuz the food's good but the
thing is no one makes their own
condiments
so just for impressing other people if
you make your own condiments people are
gonna be like holy [ __ ] this person
serious about cooking so in terms of the
condiments one could make onion jam is
one of the easier condiments and one of
the more delicious so you know there's
there's kind of social benefits to
making it as well potentially so yeah
it's good stuff
make some onion Jim now Greg can you
respond to the pretty serious
allegations on Instagram a lot of people
are suggesting that in the process of
cooking this onion jam that you were
indeed
eating onions as a hand fruit is there
any substance behind these allegations
there's not so there I guess there is a
tiny tiny bit of truth behind them so
completely true story when I was a young
child I mean I still like onions onions
and garlic I just love them I use them
in everything but when I was a young
child I guess I liked onions even more
than I do now and when my mom would take
me to the grocery store me and my
brother
she'd say like oh if you want to pick
out some fruit to eat on the ride home
go for it and my brother would always
get a Red Delicious apple because he's a
filthy conformist and me big brain move
I'd always get an onion and so you know
a little like three-year-old Greg would
be just you you know like mom would peel
the onion for me and I would just eat it
like an apple on the way home but I I
have not done that in the last how old
am i I haven't I haven't done that in
probably 22 or 23 years that rumor was
started by myself when I bought a bunch
of onions to make onion jam and like we
have a we have a little like fruit
basket on the counter and so it was a
fruit basket with like nine onions and
then like an apple and two bananas I
posted on Instagram something like you
know a good way to stick to your diet is
to make sure you have fresh fruits and
vegetables around to snack on when you
get hungry
such as onions I don't know I thought it
I thought it was an obvious enough joke
but no lie within the next like 18 hours
I got about a hundred and forty messages
from that story and there were there
were like probably twenty or thirty
people that that thought it was
hilarious clearly knew it was a joke and
then I'm sure that there were more who
like were responding to the joke with
the joke of oh you eat raw onions but
it's hard to pick up sarcasm but
I'm sure that there were within that
group of people at least 50 that were
just like what the [ __ ] dude like are
you serious and no I was not I just had
a bunch of onions on hand to make onion
jam I'm glad we could clear that up for
everybody so yeah all the positive
feedback on Greg's
recipes I feel like Greg has become very
emboldened in the kitchen so he's going
for these very complex flavors the onion
jam like I said was really terrific
he also made like a green tea ginger ice
cream that was extremely interesting
flavor very very good so he's going a
bit mad now that he's got a little more
confidence from the internet for his
cooking so he's really pushing the
envelope a little bit no I just have
more time to cook now that I'm not in
school fair enough
all right so that does it for this for
this week's episode after the music
we've got a very good interview with
Alex
Coley Ari Turner and he is doing a
really interesting study right now they
are looking at my own nuclei number in
skeletal muscle and they're specifically
studying this in males I believe between
the age 20 and 40 who are either
currently or have been using anabolic
steroids so he is currently recruiting
for that study so if you hear about it
in the interview and you think it sounds
interesting be sure to reach out to Alex
we will make his contact information
available so enjoy the interview and
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this is your host eric trikes
leur today I am joined by Greg knuckles
and also Alex Colley Ari Turner so Alex
thank you for joining us today thank you
for having me Eric and Greg of course so
Alex can you tell us a little bit about
about yourself you're you're doing a PhD
right now so where are you going to
school and what are you studying
so I'm a second year PhD student at the
University of Brighton which is on the
south coast of England for anyone that's
not familiar and my PhD is investigating
if muscle exhibits a memory of anabolic
steroid exposure so do you come from
a like a sports background personally so
I come back from a biology background
and then wanted to get into sports
science and when I look I was living in
Brighton at the time and when I
approached the postgraduate department I
specifically wanted to work with my
professor and he was on different topic
actually and when I started talking to
him it turned out he had this project in
line and since then I then enrolled to
to help him get this project off the
ground yeah because you did your
undergraduate degree was in biology at
Oxford right that's correct and so you
basically your interest in my own nuclei
and doping that kind of came after
meeting your current advisor is that
right yes I actually saw him on a
documentary where he was talking about
how he's trying to generate a new drug
test for every photo eaten or epi which
is a drug that's commonly used or has
been commonly used in the Tour de France
to enhance endurance performance and
he's trying to come up with a new drug
test and has spent about 10 years doing
that and I originally approached him to
want to help him to do that because my
undergrad degree involved a lot of
learning about sequencing technology and
he was applying the ohmic technologies
so transcriptomics which is why I was
particularly interesting but also
proteomics and metabolomics to try and
enhance the EPO
detection window that and at the same
time when we're having that conversation
he said that projects coming close to an
end and that the next project he has
coming up would be investigating if
muscle exhibits us memory of anabolic
steroid exposure yeah and I mean so you
Greg and I were just last week we were
all in London for the European
powerlifting conference and we got a
chance to talk a little bit and it
sounds like the project you're working
on has really huge ramifications for for
high-level sport when it comes to doping
but before we get into that specific
project can you give us a little bit
about a little bit of a background about
satellite cells in my own nuclei and why
they're so important when it comes to
hypertrophy and doping and sport in
general sure so we have to think about
muscle as a special tissue in the body
because it's multinucleated so unlike
skin cells or liver cells or kidney
cells where there's one nucleus inside
at one singular cellular body muscle is
actually in a something called a
syncytium which means it's
multinucleated so with inside one
cellular body with inside one fiber
there's many many nuclei and the reason
for that is because muscle cells by
volume are the largest cells inside the
human body
so one nucleus would not be able to
support the volume of such a large cell
so it has to have many nuclei inside the
cellular body now these nuclei are
important when we're talking about
muscle growth because they are the
structural units that are responsible
for making proteins and the interesting
thing about my nuclei is it's believed
that there is only a fixed volume around
a my nucleus in which proteins can be
made so if you're wanting to enhance the
size of a muscle they obviously want
muscle protein synthesis to outweigh
muscle protein breakdown so you want to
stimulate the nuclei that are inside
that muscle fiber to make more proteins
but there's only a fixed distance in
which those proteins can diffuse around
the nucleus so if the number of nuclei
are fixed inside the muscle fiber it's
only going to be able to grow
to a certain size because the diffusion
distance of from these nuclei of the
proteins is capped and so what has to
happen for the muscle fiber to get
beyond a certain size is the stem cells
that surround the muscle fiber which are
called satellite cells have to become
activated they then proliferate which
means they divide and then they donate
their nuclei into the muscle fiber and
they then become Maya nuclei themselves
and therefore the number of mynique
aligned the fiber has increased you then
have more structural units to make
proteins and so the fiber can then grow
to a bigger size than it was in the past
and that's that's the mechanism in which
satellites are important to muscle
growth now a lot of studies seem to
measure satellite cells but but not my
own nuclei specifically why is that in
the past my nickel I were particularly
difficult to count accurately because
you have to be able to stain the muscle
fiber itself and then a my nucleus a
true my Nicholas it's the center of its
nucleus is inside the the muscle fiber
in the satellite cells are just outside
and so there was some difficulty in
trying to stain and differentiate those
two nuclei and now there's actually my
Nikolai's specific dyes that exists and
stains so that is much easier to do now
so there's been basically some
improvements in the methodology that
allow us to now get directly to the
measurement we were really hoping for in
the first place that's exactly it
and that's actually caused a big
paradigm shift in muscle atrophy because
what was originally believed was once a
muscle fiber hypertrophy xand gets
bigger and the number of nuclei
increases when that muscle fiber then
shrinks and experience atrophy
it used to be believed that the number
of my nuclei would go down and as the
fiber shrinks the nuclei decrease as
well but actually it's turned out that
other nuclei inside the muscle fiber
decrease during atrophy so the number of
satellite cells might decrease the
number of nuclei of blood capillaries
might decrease
and immune cell nuclei within the muscle
fiber might decrease but the my Nikolai
themselves seem to be protected for
during this condition of atrophy and the
laboratory that's responsible for that
finding is based out of Oslo there's
three key researchers that were involved
in that one was Christian Gunderson
the other one was Joe Christie and Bruce
guard and the last one was Ingrid Ingrid
agna and they conducted some very
sophisticated experiments where they
would subject a mice to a hypertrophic
condition so it would build muscle and
then they would then it
subject the mice to an actual firing
condition and make it lose muscle and
what they would do is just before they
were exposed it to the at refined
condition they'd cut the mice open
they'd inject a dye into us into the
muscle fibers and then they would look
at the number of my nuclei side that
fibre then they'd stitch the mice back
up they'd exposed the mice to the at
refined condition and at the end of the
at refine condition they'd opened the
mice back up again and they'd go back in
and look at that very specific fiber
that they injected the dye to and then
see what happened to the number of
nuclei and so in three different cases
of an atrophying condition which was
suspending the hind limbs of the leg of
the mice in the air so that the mice did
not walk around so there was no
contraction of the back legs so they
atrophied and the other two conditions
were chemically blocking the nervous
supply to the muscle so again the muscle
couldn't contract so it atrophied or
surgically removing the nervous supply
to the muscle so again he couldn't
contract so atrophied and in all three
of those cases when they looked at the
same Myer nuclei before and after the at
refined condition the number of my
nuclei stayed exactly the same and in
the exact same place but the fiber
itself the cylinder of the muscle fiber
shrunk down in size and so that led them
to believe that the my Nikolai that
accumulate for muscle hypertrophy are
retained even during at refined
conditions and that went against the
previous literature where they were
actually only looking at markers of
nuclear degradation and they always saw
markers of nuclear degradation after
atrophy but it turns out they weren't
measuring my nuclei specific
and it was actually other nucleoside the
muscle cells that were dying off and
this led Christian Gundersen to come up
with a new model of muscle atrophy
muscle hypertrophy and attribute in
which the nuclei that accumulate from
hypertrophy are protected during atrophy
and if they remain in theory what should
then happen is if you then expose the
muscle to a second hypertrophic stimulus
it should grow at a much quicker rate
the second time around and that is the
molecular mechanism of muscle memory and
is in his opinion how if someone lose
muscle mass they can then build their
muscle back up and at a much quicker
rate the second time around then it ever
took them to build it in the first place
so if you are an accident and you break
a leg and your leg is in a cast and your
leg loses muscle mass when you're
healthy and you can get back into
training you can build your muscle back
up to where it was much quicker than it
took you to build the muscle in the
first place and that's because those my
new Collider were incorporated into your
muscle in the first place are retained
and then allow for an enhanced rate of
protein synthesis upon a second exposure
to a hypertrophic stimulus and that's
the molecular mechanism of muscle memory
and Kristin Gunderson if you're
interested anyone listening has got a
fantastic review paper that's free on
that so if you just google Christian
Gunderson muscle memory you'll find it
and in that paper he argues that this is
actually an evolutionary mechanism to
prefer some muscle mass because it would
make sense in mammals that in times of
plentiful food that you would put muscle
mass on you'd accumulate my new client
side your cells and then in times of
famine and atrophy or in the winter when
you're not as active in an evolutionary
sense and you lost muscle mass it would
make sense that when it comes around to
a following summer that you put that
muscle that you previously had on much
quick much quicker and the retained mine
UQ lay inside your fibers can then
facilitate that and so enhance muscle
memory now so that's that's the proposal
for how that all works right but when we
were both in London recently we were
chatting about the fact that there's
apparently another recent study from
a group in America that did not support
that model so would you mind just
briefly discussing that study and B now
that there is at least some level of
counter evidence against that mark
against that model discuss where this
theory stands currently so I painted a
lovely picture there and that's what the
research of that lab in Oslo has done
but as Greg mentioned last month a
research study was published in mice and
at the University of Kentucky in John
McCarthy's laboratory and Duncan is the
lead author on that paper
and in that paper they hypertrophied
mice by subjecting them to running on a
wheel that was progressively overloaded
and weighted by one gram every week so
they started on an empty wheel and every
week one gram was added for eight weeks
and at the end of that eight weeks the
muscles inside the plantaris muscle of
those mice hypertrophied they got bigger
and the number of Maya nuclei increased
but then they D trained those mice and
left them and they did nothing
and then when they reanalyzed the muscle
it turned out that they're my nuclei
numbers had actually decreased and the
muscle fibers had shrank down to the
exact same size that they were before
and so that directly challenges the
theory that the monocle I that
accumulate from hypertrophy are retained
and that's the first study that's been
published has shown that after
hypertrophy the Monica Lila have
accumulated are lost so that has led to
a challenge on this theory and further
research is going to be required to
investigate why is it Those mind you
kill I were lost and why is it that in
the previous studies they were indeed
retained it may do have something do to
do possibly with fiber type or it may
also have something to do with us just
better understanding the pathway of a
satellite cell proliferating and then
donating its nucleus in time the fiber
and it becoming a true my nucleus
because that's obviously a time course
where the nucleus is at some point a
satellite cell nucleus and then it
becomes a Maya nucleus and there's
actually a change in nuclear proteins
that can be observed that eventually
result
being classified as a true my Nicholas
so maybe the nuclei that were removed in
this study had not become true my
Nikolai yet they were still sort of late
stage satellite cell not full stage Mar
Nikolai yet so that could be one reason
but this is all postulation and further
research is going to have to investigate
what results in a my nucleus being
protected from degradation and what
doesn't because that has big
implications on doping in terms of
steroids accumulating my Nikolai and
also big accumulation are big importance
with sarcopenia and elderly people
potentially losing my new Kalia as they
get older which could be one way that we
could prevent losses in muscle mass as
people get older which is obviously big
importance as we have a increase in the
aging population and enhanced percentage
of people becoming old and frail so I
I'm glad you mentioned steroids in in
that last comment because that is kind
of the the thrust of the PhD project
that you're doing so so just briefly how
do or how does dough being and
specifically androgenic anabolic
steroids how do they affect my nuclei
what what current research is there out
there on on how steroids affect my own
nuclei and how might that then
contribute to muscle memory and you know
maybe inform doping bands and and just
practically how how would this affect
how doping control and sport work in
general so anabolic androgenic steroids
inside the body have the ability to bind
to their receptor which is called the
antigen receptor and satellite cells
contain androgen receptors and anabolic
steroids can activate satellite cells to
proliferate and to donate their nuclei
inside the muscle fibers and that's even
in the absence of any resistance
training and we know that's the case in
humans from testosterone administration
studies that were conducted in the early
2000s by North Accords
hakim and you can see in that paper that
they give graded amounts of testosterone
up to 600 milligrams a week and my
nikolai accumulation occurs in their
muscle fibers at the end of the steroid
exposure so that that means anabolic
steroids they increase muscle mass by
two ways they firstly increase the rate
at which proteins are made inside the
muscle so any pre-existing nuclei side
the muscle will make proteins at a
faster rate so that will make the fibers
get bigger but then additionally they
then also cause mind you collide to get
put into the fibers so then the protein
synthetic capacity of the cell is
increased so it's by that other
mechanism also increasing muscle growth
and you asked about what research has
been conducted in terms of anabolic
steroids of muscle memory in 2013 their
oslo laboratory that i mentioned before
that published a paper with the lead
author was ingrid Egmore and in that
paper they exposed mice to testosterone
for two weeks and at the end of the two
weeks as expected their muscle fibers
were enlarged and the number of nuclei
had gone up and at the same time they
also had a control group in this study
where they gave them a placebo and at
the end of this two weeks in both groups
they removed the testosterone pellet or
the placebo pellet and then they left
the mice in their cages doing nothing
for three months which is twelve percent
of the mices lifespan and at the end of
that three-month period the number of my
nuclei were still elevated by 28% in the
group that was previously exposed to
anabolic steroids compared to the
control group yet at that exact same
time point their fibers had shrank down
to the exact same size so even the
fibers were the same size the nuclei was
still elevated in the group that was
previously exposed to anabolic steroids
by 28% and at that time point they
exposed the mice to a hypertrophic
stimulus and that lasted for two weeks
and after six days the mice that were
previously exposed to anabolic steroids
their muscle fibers increased in size by
30% whereas the mice that were not
previously supposed to anabolic steroids
their muscle fibers only increased in
size by
6% and at the end of that two-week
period the muscle fibers grew in
parallel but the the group that was
previously exposed to anabolic steroids
their muscles of fibers were still 20%
larger compared to the group that was
not previously exposed to anabolic
steroids and so the conclusion of that
paper was the Mayan eagle-eye that
accumulate from anabolic steroid usage
in mice are retained and they then
result in a enhanced rate of protein
synthesis later down the line and so
those muscles of those mice that were
previously exposed to anabolic steroids
could or could build muscle at a quicker
rate then mice that had never been
exposed to previously to anabolic
steroids even if they hadn't been
exposed to steroids for over 12% of
their lifespan and that obviously puts
in a big question for humans because if
we know that anabolic steroids increase
my niculae numbers in humans the
question is do those mynique line
numbers go down as time passes and
there's not been a single study that has
investigated that and that is why our
research has decided to investigate that
what we can do is look back in the
research of any research has been
conducted on past steroid users because
if past steroid users are still
retaining high levels of my nuclei side
their muscles which you'd theorized
would happen because of their steroid
usage then that might provide indirect
evidence that the my nuclei that
accumulate from steroid usage in humans
are indeed retained and there's been one
research study that was conducted and
that was published in 2006 by andis
Erickson and that was just a PhD thesis
he recruited seven current anabolic
steroid users and and of just double
check how many past uses so he recruited
nine current anabolic steroid users who
at the time in the biopsy were using on
average about 1,000 milligrams of
anabolic steroids and he also recruited
seven past anabolic steroid users and in
those past anabolic steroid users they
had stopped using steroids for an
average of eight years and previously in
their life they'd used
for roughly four and a half years and in
that study they biopsy both the
trapezius muscle and the vastus
lateralis would outer quadricep muscle
and in the trapezius muscle it was shown
that in the powerlifters that had
previously taken anabolic steroids
they're my new Kleiner's were indeed
still elevated and actually higher than
a powerlifters that had never used
anabolic steroids before even though on
average these guys who stopped taking
anabolic steroids eight years ago and so
that's a particularly interesting
finding was that my only a number or
density I believe it's my nuclei number
per fiber okay okay yeah number of mine
you cannae per fiber and that that the
current uses in that group so the nine
anabolic steroid uses the current uses
in that group they've also been some
peer-reviewed published literature on
their on their trapezius muscle and that
was published by Faraz ekd in the year
2000 and they were that was the the
research paper that was shown that the
percentage of my nuclei expressing the
androgen receptor is much higher in the
trapezius muscle compared to the vastus
lateralis in untrained people in trained
people and then that disparities and
even further enhanced in people that are
taking anabolic steroids so the
trapezius muscle the percentage of mine
you can either depress the androgen
receptor is is high and even higher if
you take anabolic steroids and so that
might be the reason why these monacle
are potentially being retained but
there's very little research on
trapezius muscle biopsies but because
that's the muscle that has potentially
been shown to have a elevated number of
man you collide years after the
cessation of usage that's the muscle
we're using on in our research and I'd
also note from that research study
there's also its unpublished but there's
a report that you can read online from
that same cohort of people where they
actually looked inside the just what
proteins are inside the muscle of those
guys and using two-dimensional
proteomics they detected
2300 proteins inside the muscle tissue
and in some guys that even though they'd
stop using steroids 10 years ago they
still had 80 different proteins inside
their muscle compared to people that had
never taken anabolic steroids before so
it seems to be that the antigen receptor
the binding that's been going on and the
proteins that have been made inside that
muscle cell had made different proteins
and they seem to have been retained many
many years after the cessation of usage
which is very interesting and there's
not really been any other research
conducted on past anabolic steroid users
since then so that that's really
interesting so just for the audience
listening this is an area that I
personally find pretty fascinating and
up to this point most of the research
that that Alex had had mentioned I was
at least somewhat familiar with but Alex
I had not heard about that most or that
last report that you mentioned ooh what
was there more information about that
like was there any information about
what types of proteins there were or you
know was it more just kind of like a
little note that like oh there were 80
that differed or did it go into more
detail unfortunately they don't go into
the detail of the exact proteins and I
think that's because the technology they
were using they I don't they'd at the
moment having distinguished them either
haven't seen that this is a this is a
report on the water website it's an it's
not being peer-reviewed and then it's up
in the published literature so maybe at
some point it will but I haven't seen
and seen them specifically discuss what
proteins are indeed different gotcha
yeah I I was just wondering because
there's I mean just in kind of like the
way that Bros in the gym talked about
steroids they talked about you know not
just changes in muscle size and then
changes in contractile function one
would expect to come with the muscle
size but they also you know talk about
different functional changes that
steroids might bring about that to my
knowledge there's not much
evidence for but if those 80 proteins
were ones that that would at least
theoretically significantly affect
muscle function that that would be quite
interesting okay so we've talked about
Greg can I specifically ask what you
mean by those other changes in function
just as I I don't I don't know like
those anecdotes what do you mean by that
so some people propose that steroids
make the muscles much much much more
resilient against muscle damage some
people propose that steroids
dramatically increase contractile force
independent of cross sectional area so
you know so like specific tension would
increase along with cross sectional area
increasing which actually runs counter
to some of the research that's out there
by you and colleagues 2014 but yeah just
just various things like that which I I
kind of think is probably some you know
some dude did steroids at some point
noted some differences and then that
anecdote just kind of became you know
the the Word of God on whatever forum
this person was a prolific poster on but
yeah I mean kind of planted the idea in
people's heads and so they they kept an
eye out for it yeah pretty much cool
yeah so yeah we we've talked about Myra
nuclei in general we've talked about how
doping affects my own nuclei and how
that could potentially lead to lead to
to maybe long term differences in
hypertrophy so what what exactly are you
doing with your study Alex and what what
is that going to add to the literature
here so we're specifically looking for
men aged 20 to 40 years old and who are
current anabolic steroid users who
ideally come to visit our laboratory
towards the end of their steroid cycle
when they're exposed to super
physiological
and then soon after their visit they
will then cycle off anabolic steroids
they'll conduct their own post cycle
therapy so they won't go and drop down
to a replacement dose of testosterone
they will conduct their own post
psychotherapy to fully come off anabolic
steroids and then we invite them back
for sampling six months later and
because we are taking muscle biopsies
and also and measuring muscle mass we
have will therefore get an indication of
how much muscle mass to someone maintain
or lose when they come off an anabolic
steroid cycle and at the molecular level
we will have a comparison of muscle that
was exposed to super physiological
levels of an androgen receptor binding
and then six months later is no longer
exposed to super physiological levels of
androgen receptor binding so we'll be
able to look at the my nuclei numbers
are they retained and elevated six
months later and also in terms of
pathways of growth because you've had
super physiological event levels of
androgen receptor binding how does that
compare six months later down the line
and as far as I know there's never been
any studies published in the literature
on gene expression inside the muscle of
someone exposed to super physiological
levels and it's only ever been in guys
who is opposed to replacement levels of
testosterone and or growth hormone and
we are also if someone is so ideally we
want people to who come to the lab
eventually they go off steroids and they
come back so we have a second time point
however if there are people out there
who don't are not coming off anabolic
steroids but they're still interested in
us in research and would like to
contribute to our knowledge on my nuclei
levels and steroid users gene expression
inside the muscle of steroid users which
has never been investigated before and
even what the EPI Depa genetics looks
like inside the muscle I could talk
about that a little bit later that's
also never been looked at so even if
someone is using anabolic steroids at
the moment but they're not planning on
coming off they could also come and be
involved in our research just to give us
some extra data points but ideally we're
looking for people who are then coming
off fully and at the same time we're
also looking to recruit guys who took
anabolic steroids two to four years ago
but since then have been steroid free so
we can then see are there
new client numbers still high and also
what does their molecular pathways of
growth looked like considering it's been
years since they've had super
physiological levels of androgen
receptor binding ideally those guys are
no longer on a replacement dose of
testosterone they've been fully off but
if someone's on medically supervised
genuine testosterone replacement then
they can speak to me further so we might
be able to get you involved
however ideally those people have come
fully off anabolic steroids so so not
like the people who will tell you on the
Internet
oh I'm just on trt and then it turns out
they're on like 500 milligrams a week
yes that that's not the truth
testosterone replacement dose ideally
it's 150 milligrams a week gadget and
that and if it's medically supervised
ice even better because then we know
that's genuine testosterone replacement
therapy where if someone is cruising on
a 2 3 400 milligram dosage then they're
still going to be above normal levels of
androgen receptor binding compared to
someone who's God and a normal
circulating level of testosterone who's
who's not taking anabolics and and so
this study has actually ordered me going
on for a year and we've already biopsied
30 people now 7 current users and five
past users and but as I've heard Greg
say before the most difficult part of
research is recruiting people and so
we're always looking for more people to
get involved
we have sampling dates coming up in
October 2009 teen as a 26 the 27th to
28th of October 2019 in the University
of Brighton welcome laboratories which
is actually in the Eastbourne campus
which is just a town 40 minutes away by
train from Brighton so if anyone is
available on that Saturday Sunday or
Monday in October then they should email
me because we can discuss your trip
further we can reimburse your travel
expenses to get you involved from
anywhere in England and one nights
accommodation and even if you live and
kind of nearby in Europe we might be
able to get you involved as well because
the cost of getting someone's trained
down from northern England is sometimes
the same as a flight on easyJet from a
European country so we can usually try
and work that out with somebody and and
the research is probably going to be
going on to 2020 as well so you
if you're listening to this after the
October 2019 you think wow that's
interesting I'd like to get involved
still get in touch with me because we
always have dates coming up but at some
point in 2020 the study is going to come
to an end so I want to make I want us to
make the most of this opportunity that
we have because we've we've got all the
equipment in place we have all the
personnel to do the biopsies in place
all the medical professionals we have
all the equipment ready at the
University it's now just a matter of
trying to get as many current and past
anabolic steroid users enrolled in the
research so we can make the most of this
opportunity so if anyone out there is
interested just email me you can take
the conversation further I can describe
the study a little bit more what's it
going to happen on the day can answer
any of your questions and then we can
hopefully proceed to organising your
visit either on the 26th 27th or 28th of
October or sometime in 2020 I'd like to
interject I mean recruiting for studies
is absolutely one of the most
challenging things and especially when
you're working in a really specialized
population so years ago I was recruiting
for a study on on body builders and one
of the biggest challenges was trying to
convince body builders I'm one of you
like I'm not here to like make
bodybuilding look bad I'm not here to
pass judgment on what bodybuilders do
we're just trying to learn and so I
think it's important to stress for a
study like this if you're listening and
you qualify and you're like I don't know
this is kind of a sensitive topic it's
just so important to stress how
meaningful and critical this research is
and how important the findings are so if
you're listening and you're on the fence
you're like I don't know if I want to
get involved because it's a sensitive
topic I would encourage you to really
strongly consider it and I'd also add
that the University ethics for this
project is you can imagine work hard to
come by but one of the things that we
have to adhere to to be allowed to
conduct as researches the be providing
anonymity to the participants so when
someone comes to the laboratory the only
person that interviews them about their
steroid usage is me and I'm the only
person knows what group they're in it's
not discussed with the other people that
are helping out with the study and
there's no reference to your name on on
anything that we do you're given a
random now
when you enter the labs and that's
what's written on all of your your your
samples and that that is then further
randomized later on for publication so
there's not going to be any way anyone's
going to be able to work out well even
if you took part in this research unless
you wanted to tell them so there is
anonymity guaranteed and as Eric said if
you're on the fence just email me anyway
and we can have a chat I tend to speak
to all the participants on the phone and
tell them more about what's going on
what they can expect logistics of their
travel etc etc so that we can then make
the visit as as pleasant as possible for
them yeah and this isn't when you talk
about anonymity
this isn't like when some website says
no no we're gonna protect your data and
then you find out six months later they
sold your data and there's like a big
lawsuit like I promise you if Alex
breaches that confidentiality his life
is going to be a world of pain so you
can have a tremendous deal of confidence
in that security of anonymity yeah would
not be worth it at all I've got no
interest in it and you know in the
United Kingdom we we live in a country
where the possession of anabolic
steroids is legal they're Class C drugs
so possession for personal use is not
criminalized
so even conducting this kind of research
is difficult in other countries where
that is the case where University ethics
boards would maybe question
researchers wanting to recruit people
who possessing substances that are
against the control acts of that country
whereas that's not the case in the
United Kingdom so it's one of the few
places you could even conduct research
like this which is another reason why
it's interesting it to try and get
people involved because other countries
Monto even be able to conduct this kind
of research yeah I mean they're
definitely not doing this in Sweden
right
Oh Denmark isn't isn't isn't sweet in
the place where if you're too jacked
like the the police will just come into
the gym and drug test you well I know I
don't know who Sweden but in in Denmark
I know
if you've ever seen the film under
construction - with Dave Crossland he
goes and visits gyms in Denmark and he
talks at the anti-doping Denmark and
they explain that the gyms can sign up
to have drug testing at the gym level so
people anti-doping Denmark can walk into
a commercial gym and they can drug test
some people just at random obviously
depending on their appearance and in the
in the film he they explained that at
the front door of the gym they have to
display a smiley face which explain
which indicates drug testing happens or
a sad face which indicates drug testing
doesn't happen it's like the surgeon
general's warning on pack of cigarettes
they need to update that it should be if
there's no drug testing it should be a
winky face
and so and so Dave in that film goes and
visits these different gyms and I think
a lot of the gyms that sad faces just
don't put the picture up but still a
fact that does happen so it just goes to
show you how strict the rulings are and
if you're caught taking steroids even if
you're just a gym goer and you can then
be served an anti-doping violation and
not be allowed to train at the
commercial gyms anymore and you're kind
of blacklisted so you know that's very
different it's very very different to
how is another country so literal
real-life natty police yeah but that's
just because they have different rulings
I courage out anyone to go and watch
that watched under construction - you've
got a you can stream it it's not
expensive and I think Dave does a really
good job trying to navigate that space
when he goes and visits yes my
understanding I could be wrong so if
you're listening and you know about this
- correct me we people listen to our
show in every country except the
Netherlands so somebody will let me know
if we're wrong but I believe in Sweden
purely based on appearance they can kind
of flag you as a suspected steroid user
and then conduct a mandatory drug test
and I believe they can charge you with
criminal possession of stare
because it is in your system at that
time so even if you don't have like
steroids in your car or at your house or
whatever the fact that it is present in
your body I believe is a makes you
subject to criminal charges yeah that's
that's that's what I heard as well I
haven't heard that but that's
interesting but that's a good segue
because I mean the research that you're
doing has really high potential to
influence all sorts of anti-doping
policy in the future so do you guys is
that kind of part of the part of the
intention here is to figure out how long
a ban should be for when someone who
competes in sport gets caught with a
steroid violation well research is
investigating that but it's never gonna
prevail but provide a concrete answer
because obviously we only won one study
and depending on the and the people we
can get it'd be very difficult to
extrapolate that to all people but we
are definitely gonna add shine a further
light on to my nicolai retention post
steroid usage as that's never been
properly investigated in humans but has
been rigorously tested now and mice so
that that work that will be interesting
and but I would add that a lifetime ban
is never going to happen in anti-doping
and because for the first time offenses
anyway because law wise and the lawyers
are involved in anti-doping that would
just never pass and and that's why
that's not the case as it currently
stands we're at the moment is a
four-year ban if you're caught with a
prohibited drug if you're caught with a
second offense the ban is then
customized depending on the severity of
the offense which can be up to a
lifetime ban if it was blatant cheating
but if the second offense was proven to
be contaminated or indirect or
inadvertent then it can be reduced and
less but I don't think that first-time
offense is ever going to result in
lifetime bans even if anabolic steroids
were shown that they mynique lied that
they
accumulator retained maybe it might
result in a slight extension on the band
for steroids specifically if they're
fixed on muscle slightly longer lasting
whereas for example if someone takes a
stimulant or an amphetamine and gets a
boost prior to an event you know a few
years later that's never going to
benefit them whereas it might be if
their steroid use cycle does retain the
benefit in their muscle many months
later maybe maybe the bad link might be
extended on that but the other end
starting to deal with the lawyer aspect
of anti-doping uh and that was probably
not going to change for some time yes
just to clarify currently the system is
you get you get caught the first time
that's an automatic four-year ban unless
it can be proven that you're it was
inadvertent exposure so if you prove it
was a genuine contaminated supplement so
the supplement you were using and
supplements that then take had taken
from the supply chain with the same
batch number then both proven to contain
trace amounts of a drug that was not on
the label and therefore was inadvertent
as consumption it can be reduced down
for four years equally if you have a
genuine need for a drug but you have not
filled out the correct therapeutic use
exemption for then and you're found with
that drug in your system so some people
have to take drugs that and that could
actually mask other drugs but they
actually required to help monitor their
blood pressure or something along those
lines but they used also to mask steroid
usage if it's proven that you have to
take that drug because otherwise you'd
suffer from a medical condition but you
didn't fill out the appropriate
paperwork then the four-year ban could
be reduced but if inadvertent or
consumption or therapeutic reasons are
not ruled out then yeah it's a four year
it's a four you been and so obviously
the the research that you're working on
now is going to really help us
understand this timeline with a lot a
much clearer understanding but I mean do
you think that for years it is
sufficient currently when it comes to
you know if we catch somebody using
anabolic steroids so you think a
four-year ban is enough to actually
mitigate the advantage that was obtained
I think it's always gonna defend well if
we're talking about steroids causing my
nickel accumulation the level of my
nickel accumulation is always going to
depend on the dosage of steroids use the
length of exposure and the types of
drugs used and and we even if we do find
that my nickel I are indeed retained
after steroid usage so they're not going
down we don't really know how if that
may manifest in what and what level does
that manifest itself in a benefit inside
somebody's muscle because the theorized
benefit would be if you're my new clone
umbers are always still high the protein
synthetic rate of that muscle could
always be higher than it was when the my
new clone numbers were lower so that
would mean that your muscle fibers might
be able to grow to a bigger size however
if you're no longer taking steroids
anymore then the protein synthetic rate
inside your muscle is going to be lower
so maybe it's can even if it has more
money could I maybe it can't even grow
as big as it ever was in the past that's
that's definitely not going to be
happening but you know you might not be
able to put on muscle mass better even
if you have higher numbers of my Nikolay
you might recover better because your
protein synthetic right inside the
muscle might be higher so that could be
one retained advantage and but dude is
four years or not I don't I don't know
and i think our study is only gonna
slightly shine light on that because
we're not controlling the steroid cycles
of these individuals we're not
controlling their training or their
nutrition in an ideal world what we
won't be able to do is give people
anabolic steroids train them see how
much muscle they put on how many money
collide they accumulate and then take
them off anabolic steroids probably keep
their training going and then just kind
of see what's their rate of muscle
growth light later down the line and
what's their my new Clio numbers later
down the line that would truly answer
this quiz that question but at least
hopefully with this study if we get
enough people to return on the second
occasion and we get enough past users
then we can further investigate that
retention mechanism and is this a line
of research that you're
you're planning on continuing kind of
down the line in your career so our
group is also because investigating the
issue of incorporating fairly
transgendered individuals into sport
because a man a biological male sis man
who's has a testosterone level a high
testosterone level up to the year of
transition so say that's in their 20s
then they've had past puberty maybe ten
or more years of a high testosterone
environment which would you theorized
would mean high levels of my Nikolai and
then the question is when they then
undergo hormonal therapy and they reduce
their testosterone and they become a
female did their numbers of mynique
alive remain elevated or not and that's
never been fully investigated and so in
line with this research we're doing on
anabolic steroids and muscle memory we
want to look at muscle memory in
transgendered individuals and so we have
submitted the ethical approval for a
study in which we will monitor 20
individuals transitioning either
direction I'm not that's not my main
project my main project is this anabolic
steroid
muscle memory project dr. Jonathan
ospina bettan Kerr is heading the
transgender project and we're hoping to
hear back very shortly about with the
ethics was submitted and there were some
as you can imagine that's a very
difficult study to try and conduct and
many many things have to be considered
and the ethical level to make sure
participants looked after and so there
were some critiques and now those
critiques have been actioned and
rightfully so and been resubmitted and
we're waiting to hear back from that and
but I would hope that in the next year
or so that that will study will be up
and running and hopefully I'll be able
to contribute to that because it will be
happening at the university bottom with
our group yeah I mean I don't know if
you've followed along but there have
been a couple pretty big news stories
here in the States about transgender
athletes competing in powerlifting so
you know in the kind of circles online
that Greg and I see and participate in
there's been a really active
gushin about how to address
incorporating transgender athletes into
competitive sports that are that have
you know male and female or men's and
women's classes within the sport so that
I mean that's gonna be critically
important research I'm really excited to
see what you guys find with that study I
feel like discussion might be an overly
polite way to describe the discourse so
I actually have I have another kind of
like more basic science question about
satellite cells and in Myer nuclei the
this is something that I meant to ask
early on but conversation went as it did
but I'm still kind of asking somewhat
selfishly because it's something I'm
interested in so as we covered kind of
at the top of the interview a lot of
especially the older studies looked at
satellite cells specifically but not so
much Maira nuclei so I'm wondering if if
someone were to go back and read those
old old studies to to what degree do or
to what degree does satellite cell
activation proliferation to what degree
is that predictive of eventual my own
nuclear accretion one - what do we know
about kind of what mechanistically
causes or contributes to my own nuclear
accretion and then 3 do satellite cells
themselves do anything interesting or
potentially useful so like basically if
there are satellite cells hanging out
that aren't my nuclei you don't go on to
become or they don't go on to donate
their nuclei are they still doing
anything for us or they just kind of
hanging out there so I would say that
I'll just answer that first question you
see the last question you said where the
satellite cells are they just sort of
hanging out from what I've read it seems
to be that when a satellite cell is
activated to proliferate
one this the cell will divide into one
of those cells will then remain a
resident satellite cell and the other
one is then destined down the pathway to
become a my nuclei okay at room and
nuclei proper and the reason why said
there seems to be basically when the
cell divides nuclear factors inside one
of the cells will cause it to stay a
satellite cell and nuclear the factors
decide the others will cause the change
in expression is required to for it to
become a mind you collide proper my
nucleus proper and the reason why this
the original stell says as a satellite
cell is so as to not deplete the
satellite cell pull inside your muscle
because you wouldn't want to run out of
satellite cells because of all of them
have become my nuclei because then you
couldn't grow again in the future and
and we do know we do know that as you
get older the number of satellite cells
as they are stem cells just decline
inside your muscle and that's what one
one of the reasons it in conjunction
with the decline in testosterone levels
people provide far find it harder to put
on muscle mass as they get older and
there is a your other questions what is
it that causes a satellite cell to
become activated to proliferate to
become a mind you collide proper that's
a really good question it seems to be
there the pathways of muscle growth of
involved in doing that and it needs to
be further elucidated as what why is it
that what happens that causes that to
happen and just the other way that the
muscle fiber can grow is just that
protein synthesis goes up and the fiber
kind of expands and some of the other
research it seems to be that once the
fiber reaches a critical threshold
growth beyond that point occurs via the
mind you collide accretion but what
exactly is required specifically for
that to happen needs to be I'd say
further investigated it would be great
if you could work that out because then
you could sort of cause some really good
muscle growth and what was the first
question again you asked was that oh so
the older studies that just looked at
satellite cell stuff that were
specifically measuring my nuclei
if someone were to go back and read them
how how well would like group level
changes in satellite cell stuff
depending on what was actually measured
be a good long-term predictor of my
nuclear accretion right
you'd see it well in in the atrophying
studies it seems to be that satellite
cells do die off when a muscle atrophies
mhm but the mine you kill a retained and
because those old studies were just when
they they didn't specifically use any
microscopy work they just looked at
markers of nuclear degradation and they
always saw this signs of nuclear
degredation and so the conclusion was
nuclei are going down my nuclei are
going down but it now nowadays with
specific markers to look at each
separate nucleus they've seen the
satellite cells do die off and but my
nickel I don't so I I was thinking more
like under hypertrophic conditions so
you know maybe two groups do two
different training programs what we see
in the reasonably short term is changes
in cross sectional area are similar but
one group had a larger increase in
satellite cells would would that lead
you as someone who knows a lot more
about this than I do would that lead you
to believe that the group that had the
larger increase in satellite cells is
probably going to get more my own
nuclear accretion and possibly more
hypertrophy down the road or is just
measuring satellite cells in the absence
of actually measuring my own nuclei like
is that able to tell you that I would
say that yeah I think if you saw the
satellite cell number go up then you'd
then see my Nikolay accretion if if the
hypertrophic stimulus you're providing
was sustained for long enough because
there's there's a time course for
satellite cell donation it's not just a
switch that suddenly turned on and two
minutes later the satellite sail has
become a mine nuclei it's there seems to
be a time course and a slow progressive
change away from being a true satellite
cell and
coming a true my nuchal I and so you
could imagine that if you've got more
satellite sales than they're great but
if the hypertrophic stimulus is
sustained then a high percentage of
those are going to start to transition
into mind you can live proper and you
can see when anabolic steroids are given
in the administration studies in humans
that the number of satellite cells go up
and they then go back down after
anabolic steroids as well so that sort
of answers a question very cool I did
not know that in studies I've seen that
just measure satellite cells I just to
this point I've just kind of looked at
that in shrugged and said oh that's cool
I I didn't know that it was that
straightforward that kind of like
eventually they will become my nuclei
and it just sort of takes a while yeah
if if I would say if the hypertrophy
sickness was sustained and long enough
and in the furrows ekd papers where they
seemed to believe that because of this
there's a ceiling to the size of the
muscle fiber that and if the number of
nuclei stay the same because there's a
diffusion distance which the proteins go
away from the nucleus there's a certain
volume of which that nucleus can provide
proteins for that muscle fiber but once
that volume is maximized the fibers not
going to grow anymore because the
proteins can't diffuse any further so
the only way it's going to get bigger is
if the satellite cells become my nuclei
so you could maybe think there is
possibly a mechanism in which the cell
can sense it's at max translational
capacity and it's a maximum maximized
these these volumes these my Nikolai the
ceiling has become close to being
reached and then the pathway of Grove
starts to switch towards my Nikolai
chrétien and that takes time so if that
you'd assume if the hypertrophic
stimulus is sustained enough that would
happen and then it's then open up for
those new nuclides then make more
proteins and then the whole cycle could
potentially repeat itself and one thing
Greg that I did want to mention that I
remember we spoke about this what not
EEP EEP see this year but I think last
year was
about the epigenetic memory of muscle
whether the c-pen studying
yeah the Seabourn study from January
2008 Eames published in Nature Reviews
he's actually published a lot more that
guy's got some really cool stuffs but
what I think is quite interesting is
when we circle back to the whole lovely
picture that Christian Gundersen has of
Monica like accumulation and then
retention during atrophy and then those
minor gly causing enhanced growth and
that if that isn't if that is not the
case because we've just got some
contradictory evidence coming out and a
scientific literature because of that it
may well be that either way then the
nuclei inside the fiber that remaining
during atrophy maybe they still have an
epi genetic memory of muscle exposure
anyway and so they can still result in
an enhanced level of growth and this
robert Seabourn study you were talking
about I think for the listeners was a
great piece of research where they had
guys come for a single resistance
training session
they then biopsied them after that and
then they then subjected them to a
sustained resistance training program
and they then barb see them at the end
of that and then they D trained them so
they did absolutely nothing and then
they biopsied them again at the end of
that and then they've retrained them for
a period of time and then biopsied them
again and what they found in that study
was certain areas of certain genes were
opened up for expression that are to do
with muscle anabolism even after one
resistance training session and then
there then they remain open after
sustained period of training and then
when you stop training those areas that
don't fully close that are responsible
for anabolism and then when you go back
to training they open up even further
and then result in even for a higher
expression of these genes that are
involved in anabolism and so even if the
my nuclei retention theory is
questionable because it maybe depends on
the lifecycle of a satellite cell
turning into a monocle i and maybe
they're not fully retained after
hypertrophy still the regions of DNA
inside those Martin E coli
that exposed the hypertrophic stimulus
may remain open after that hypertrophic
stimulus and then when you go back to
training they can then become reopened
and express their genes at an even
better higher level than they did in the
past and and that was that's an amazing
piece of research and what I would know
with the anabolic steroids is that
there's never been a study that's looked
at changes in the regions of the DNA
being opened or closed because in humans
because of anabolic steroid exposure and
we're preserving the muscle inside a
genetic preservative to look at that and
I'm really excited about that personally
because you might find that because the
androgen receptor is binding to specific
regions inside the DNA of these minor
kalai causing them to make more proteins
at a super physiological levels you'd
theorized at the point of the biopsy
when someone is in that state regions of
their DNA for anabolism were going to be
open and could be totally different to
someone has never taken steroids before
and if that research that I was
mentioning about the proteins is indeed
valid and those people had 80 different
proteins even after ten years of never
taking steroids then you definitely
expect there to be some differences in
what regions are the author of the
genome inside the muscle cell are being
activated by the androgen receptor with
super physiological levels and then when
someone goes off
anabolic steroids and the receptor
binding goes drops down to normal
physiological levels the question is now
what happens to those regions of the DNA
that were opened up do they close fully
or do they remain slightly more open and
maybe that could result in a high level
of anabolism later down the line yeah
that that's really interesting that's a
really good point I mean if you're
seeing different proteins one would
assume that that might be related to
epigenetic changes min so you you you
know a lot about just basic muscle
physiology that I don't know and it's
one of those things that to me is like
both fun and frustrating because I feel
like every time I talk to you I realize
there's just so much more a that I don't
know
and be that just we as a species don't
know about how er about how our muscles
work there's just so many very cool open
questions and not that I'd add to that
as well because I remember when we met
an EPC 2018 and you told me about the
Rossetti study in mice where they
inhibited the mTOR pathway the which is
a regarded as the may main molecular
switch for protein synthesis inside
muscle the mammalian target for
rapamycin they chemically inhibited that
so you'd assume that therefore that mice
is not going to be able to grow muscle
if its main molecular switch for a
muscle muscle protein synthesis is
turned off and then they go those mice
anabolic steroids but they still
experienced muscle growth which is crazy
so that means there's a redundant system
mechanism inside muscle that anabolic
steroids are able to activate that
causes muscle growth whereas in the
other mice when they inhibited it they
didn't experience any muscle growth
exactly zoos expect and I had no idea
that that had gone on so there's some
big questions in terms of how anabolic
steroids cause muscle growth that are
just totally unanswered that we need to
conduct more research on for sure so I
think I think I'm just about out of
questions related to this specific topic
and in your research study that's
currently ongoing I do have one one
final question for you though again
mostly for my own personal benefit so
something that I've probably spent way
too much time and energy thinking about
and still don't have a good answer to is
like why in the absence of steroids or
even with steroids muscles eventually
stopped growing because like to this
point every study that's you know looked
at muscle protein synthesis and trained
lifters finds that you know their rates
of breakdown at rest don't seem to be
different from untrained people you
expose them to training maybe the area
under the care for protein synthesis
isn't quite as big when you're trained
is untrained but it still may be like
a third is big or half as big but you
know you don't see someone who's been
training for 10 years growing it a third
the rate or half the rate it's as
someone who's completely untrained and
eventually like we do all seem to kind
of hit a wall at some point and I
haven't been able to yet identify like a
really clear mechanism for why that
would be the case so like as someone who
knows a lot more about muscle physiology
than I do
can you think of any like potential
targets for things that may be
eventually
capping muscle growth for people who are
drug-free that's a really good question
and I think if you sort of adhere to the
Manulife ceiling theory then maybe it's
just at some point the level of training
that's required so your fibers grow to
this this size and maximum size then you
get more mind nuclei going in and to
then that those cells will then grow to
a bigger size but then to get even more
money like to go in maybe the level of
training that's required for that is is
so so high or maybe it's just so the
muscle then just doesn't want to add
anymore mind you clay into it then maybe
there's a there's a there's a limit to
which this muscle cell wants to add more
nuclei maybe because it gets to the
point where it thinks this is not
economical to have this size of muscle
mass its calorie expenditure or
something along those lines maybe and
even I think another thing I think is
quite interesting with sort of muscle
growth is how many ribosomes somebody
has as well because even if the my
nicolas is the unit that's responsible
for for making these transcripts these
these transcripts then have to bind to
the ribosome to then get converted into
protein and so that they're a potential
limiting step into protein synthesis
inside the muscle fiber and i didn't
realize
that the number of ribosomes that
somebody has can be inside them the
muscle can potentially be genetically
determined as people had difference in
the number of gene number of copies of
ribosomal genes they have in their DNA
and that might be one reason as to why
some people grow more muscle quicker
than other people when you expose them
to the same resistance training stimulus
so why is it that some guys put on more
muscle quicker than other guys when
they're training the same if those guys
that put on more muscle they just have
more ribosomes and that's they've seen
that in the literature then that could
be the reason to explain wise even if
this the mechanical signal for
hypertrophy is the same the rate
limiting step of making proteins if
there's just more ribosomes there more
proteins get made per unit time compared
to someone that doesn't so maybe
ribosomes have something to do with
potentially how big somebody can get as
well and I'm not I won't be surprised in
the short period of time if these DNA
testing companies that exist will try
and get you to see how many copies you
have to your maybe your propensity to
growth and maybe that's the way what I
think this would be an amazing study if
someone can go and get the top IFBB pros
get-get-get their DNA and then see how
many cut and what their ribosomal copies
are like because maybe some of the
biggest dudes we've ever seen maybe
they've got loads of vipers at the
copies of ribosomes potentially maybe
some other things you know they've got
slight my statin mutations as well and I
don't know what do you think what
someone's growth Alex don't be coy if
you want me in your study I'll do your
study don't beat around the bush it's
embarrassing I could say I could send
you your saliva cheap I have some spare
ones in the lab anytime Greg what do you
what do you think limits limits people's
growth man I don't know so I think one
potential thing might just be energetic
so there's some
research finding that like people at
baseline with with higher mitochondrial
density then experience more hypertrophy
a study in older people finding that
that folks with greater capillary
density experience more hypertrophy and
so like obviously muscle is pretty
energetically costly especially if if
it's undergoing high intensity
contractions and there's even I don't
know if there's direct evidence for this
but I've seen it at least proposed in
the literature that when muscle fibers
get too large they can start have start
having a problem like dealing with
inorganic phosphate accumulation and
that can affect contractile function and
so I'm I'm wondering if it's just a
matter of like a surface area to volume
ratio thing where once muscle fibers get
too big
it's very energetically costly to build
more protein and just to maintain the
fiber as it is mitochondrial density
tends to drop sometimes maintained
generally doesn't increase if it's just
with resistance training capillary
density per fiber tends to be maintained
but per unit of cross-sectional area
tends to decrease and so like diffusion
distance to like the median point and
the fiber increases see I I wonder if
it's just that when fibers get too big
it ceases to make sense kind of like
what you alluded to that maybe something
is eventually just telling the fiber
like it's no longer economical to get
bigger and I'm thinking that that might
have something related to to energetics
and oxygen delivery and another
potential thing that could be going on
is it seems that the the point of
[Music]
Meccano transduction is
the costumers and focal adhesion kinase
and so that could also potentially be a
surface area to volume ratio thing as
well because you know all of all of
those protein complexes that seem to be
what kicks off the int or pathway those
are all located on the outside of the
cell and the surface area of the cell
won't increase at the same rate as the
volume of the cell well and like you
know all of the proteins and stuff are
roughly synonymous with cell volume so I
mean I'm I'm thinking it's probably it's
some very basic level just a surface
area to volume ratio problem and I'm not
exactly sure whether it's you know the
int or stuff or the energy stuff or both
maybe rise ribosomes stuff but I the
more I think about it the more I think
it's just a surface area to volume ratio
problem hmm it's preventing everyone
from getting super jacked yeah I mean so
uh a way to test that I guess would be
to find people who very much seem to be
plateaued and then one to see like
whether there's kind of a common muscle
size that folks attained and at like not
muscle like not muscle cross-sectional
area best for cross sectional area and
if there's not see if the variation in
fiber cross sectional area attained at a
hypertrophic plateau is at any way
related to muscle oxygen uptake such
that people with like you would see
similar scaled muscle oxygen uptake or
greater oxygen uptake per fiber in in
the larger fibers I think that's one way
you could potentially get at it but
there's no direct research for any of
that as far as I'm aware maybe it could
be sort of worded into some sort of grow
on soccer penis
might never happen although yeah that
would make sense that that's what you
look for what do you think Eric well I
was going to say on the idea of doing
that research
I believe that Ohio State's kinesiology
department was bringing in a lot of high
level Arnold Classic competitors year
after year to do a bunch of accessable
not I don't know if they got the
bodybuilders I think they had the
strongmen coming in but that would be
like the perfect setup right if you get
the whole bodybuilding lineup from from
the Arnold Classic you could answer a
lot of really cool questions by just
getting some pretty basic observational
information from them get-get-get Dexter
Jackson guys that man is immortal did
you hear that he won a professional
bodybuilding show last week yeah he won
the Tampa Pro I mean he's had the most
IFBB Pro wins of anyone ever he's 73
years old he's one of the damn Tampa Pro
it might may be a win maybe I mean he's
the Olympia's I knew you like what a
month away so yeah I mean he may be
maybe number two for the blade that'd be
cool that would be I mean how many years
apart is that 11 year gap yeah between
the fish it was 2008 yeah that would be
so cool I'd be so happy
that'd be amazing yeah Dexter is an
amazing bodybuilder he seems pretty cool
that'd be really fun to see but on this
idea of like you know what limits muscle
growth and you know I would suspect that
it is energetic in nature because at a
certain point the energetics associated
with maintaining that degree of muscle
mass are just insane and it's hard to
think of any biological rationale to
justify that level of muscularity
evolutionary that would make sense as
well because you maybe you'd never be
able to support that kind of mass I mean
so the the thing that gets me is like so
I feel like that makes a lot of sense
when I'm just thinking about it from the
perspective of drug-free lifters but
then in the research that does exist on
on people using steroids like their
muscles do get way way bigger and there
doesn't seem to be just a tremendous
decrease in in muscle function in any
way that that we have been able to
measure so like
it it seems like it would eventually be
an energetic issue but at least I mean
you bodybuilders do still function you
know like you that that's kind of my
hang-up with it
do they I mean I haven't spent a lot of
time with with like really high level
bodybuilders that are like on drugs and
stuff I mean have you ever walked up a
staircase next to one I haven't I mean
like so I'm thinking about this kind of
from the perspective of I guess like
someone who's incredibly out of shape
and completely untrained so I mean as
out of shape as pro bodybuilders may be
I mean most most of them are at least a
lot of them do still do a fair amount of
cardio leading up to a show and even
like if usually if you just look into
the energetic costs of I don't know say
squatting 500 for a set of ten which I
assume pretty much all of the IFBB Pro
guys can do like that requires a very
very substantial amount of like rate of
energy expenditure to be able to pull
that off and then if they were just
severely severely out of shape you know
they'd be on the ground for 30 minutes
afterwards which III mean I at least get
the feeling that they're in better shape
than most power lifters who use anywhere
close to the same amount of drugs on
average and and so like I don't know if
if it's an energetic problem if it was
like a functional problem for them then
you would expect that you take someone
who's ridiculously untrained and
completely sedentary and have them start
lifting and you know it would take them
months to even begin to start growing
just because it would take so long to
get their muscles sufficiently
conditioned to grow and that doesn't
really seem to be what happens yeah I
mean I don't know we need smart people
like Alex to figure it out
we need more administration's to
that's what would be kind of useful yeah
yeah we need to actually start doing
this stuff directly
despite the ethical hang-ups involved
yeah yeah I mean so yeah the most I've
ever seen in this study is 600
milligrams where they've given guys that
for 20 weeks of testosterone and that's
I don't know it seems to be no one ever
no one wants to do administration
studies since the beginning early 2000s
nowadays so understandably so because I
mean it's you've got a question the
potential risk to people health but
there's still questions that need to be
answered on how anabolic steroids cause
muscle growth and that's the most
controlled way to do it so yeah on the
topic of like this upper limit and
what's limiting muscle growth one of the
things that I I always come back to when
I think about it is the two physiques
that kind of jump out in my mind are
Flex Lewis and Ronnie Coleman and it's
like let's say we figure out what this
limiting factor is and let's further say
that we have some kind of workaround
that allows us to push this even further
I just can't even imagine what that
looks like
and how an individual who has
meaningfully become more muscle-bound
than that goes about activities of daily
living like it just starts to get to
such an extreme level that you're like
how would that even work what would it
look like it's just crazy to even think
about but it would be so cool if we if
we could kind of push our understanding
of muscle physiology one step further
and start start getting some concrete
answers to that question I mean I'm
thinking about it not for me how how do
we make Ronnie bigger perspective but
more from a well then start thinking
about it that way that's the funnest way
to think about that I mean I I'm
thinking about it more from a
perspective of like a non-negligible
amount of drug free lifters just kind of
wind up really disappointed in their
results especially if Aker up like
idolizing
who do do a lot of gear and and we've
talked about just inherent variability
and how well people respond to training
and so I'm thinking about this less from
the perspective of how do we make the
freaks freakier and more from a
perspective of well how can we make sure
that most people can eventually get
quite solid results you know because I
would assume that you know whatever is
limiting say the biggest drug-free
bodybuilders growth and whatever is
limiting kind of the average trainees
growth is probably something pretty
similar it just took a lot longer to
limit the bigger guy and so that's
that's kind of what the perspective I'm
thinking about it from yeah that makes
sense
now Greg you and I are just a couple of
Internet keyboard warriors but alex has
important work to do
we've taken about an hour and a half of
his time it's probably about time for
him to get back to solving the world's
problems in forming wada decisions about
doping and transgender athletes so
before we end the interview here alex is
there a way that people can stay up to
date with you and your work or do you
want to give us your contact information
for anyone who might be interested in
participating in your study yeah the
best thing is if somebody emails me and
Eric I'll give you my email so you can
put it in the description and honestly
if you're on the fence about if you're a
current user you think you're in the
midst of a blast around the end of
October or you've just finished anything
man it'd be really cool to be monitored
while I come off steroids then just come
and talk to me equally if you took
steroids years ago and you had on a
genuine TRT dosage now or you've not not
not taking anything then definitely get
in touch with me and we can continue the
conversation further and also if
anyone's just listened and they think
this is an interesting research study
the best way I've managed to find
participants has been through social
media and so if you just search on
Facebook
Alex Katy muscle-memory you will see of
course a public post it can be very
easily shared that's got details of the
study
and the same I have a made an Instagram
account it's just got one single post
about the study that can easily be
shared and that's Alex underscore K
underscore T and the same thing I'd
greatly appreciate anyone who just share
the advert because you never know who's
gonna see it and social media has proven
the best way for me to find people and
so thank you if you decide to share my
other awesome well thanks so much for
joining us I think our audience is
really going to enjoy this this
interview a lot of really cool
information about muscle physiology
we're really excited to to keep an eye
out for your findings and to see you
know all the work coming out of your lab
in the future it's gonna be really
exciting so thanks so much for joining
us and we'll talk to you soon thanks for
listening to the stronger by science
podcast now Greg and I are not experts
in medicine or health or really anything
else for that matter so before you make
any changes to your diet and exercise
habits make sure you check with a doctor
or another healthcare professional if
you enjoyed this podcast and you'd like
to support it visit stronger by science
com2 check out the products and services
that we offer thanks for listening and
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you